Almost Heaven
Made you feel
You're not alone
Kappa Pong Champ
Keep a forehead
Bible Thumb
Twitch Emotes
I remember
Typing Dan's game
Forehead Swift Rage
Twitchy Molds.
Ja, die Zeit geht schnell rum, Marvin.
Glaubt man manchmal gar nicht.
Instant 13 Jahre später.
Für mich ist es noch nicht lange her.
Im Hinterkopf ist die Xbox 360 und die PS3 noch gar nicht lange outdated.
Dabei sind wir schon zwei Generationen weiter.
Kapapock-Champ.
Pipuff.
Keine Ahnung.
Twitchy-Modes.
Was ist das?
Wurde ich gehackt?
Das BSI hat Schwachstellen auf meinem Server gefunden.
Äh.
Mein Browser ist gerade abgekackt.
Chatge?
Guck mal hier, das ist die beliebte Sch...
Nein, nein, wir gucken jetzt nicht hier.
Das PSI hat Schwachstellen.
Das ist doch bestimmt
G-Baid, oder?
Jetzt ein bisschen Mario-Karten-Musik an.
So, Leute.
Da bin ich.
Woche nicht on gewesen.
Wieder am Start.
Deutlich besser als letzte Woche alles.
Exzellent.
Ist ein guter Channel, okay.
Habe ich noch nie gehört von und nie was gesehen.
Mal gleich gucken, vielleicht ist es ja was, was wir öfters mal schauen können.
Moment.
Docker ist fies.
Naja, Docker ist manchmal ein bisschen blöd, wenn man damit Sachen macht, wofür es nicht gedacht ist.
Und wenn man sich nicht darüber im Klaren ist, dass zum Beispiel Docker IP-Tables-Regeln einfügt, die komplett...
Ja genau, das ist genau das, was ich gerade sagen wollte.
Es muss einem klar sein, dass Docker Firewall-Regeln einfügt, die quasi vor den anderen Firewall-Regeln hängen.
Und es ist egal, ob du was sperrst oder nicht, du kommst drauf.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob
Potman, hat Potman nicht das gleiche Problem
mit IP-Regeln? Wobei, ehrlich gesagt,
weiß ich nicht.
Ja.
Da muss man aufpassen, wie man in Hessen
sagt. So.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal den Mini-PC
starten. Nein, in Normal-Mode.
Weil das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, Leute.
Tanzverbot, Moin!
Ja, das letzte Mal auch schon da. Hat mich auch gewundert.
Aber schön, dass du am Start bist.
So, startet das heute nochmal?
Leute, warum... Ah, jetzt. Keine Ahnung, was das wieder ist.
Geht rum.
Leute, ich muss euch was erzählen.
Ich wurde ja ein bisschen geflamed auf Twitter, weil ich ein Bild von der Gehaltsabrechnung
im März glaube ich gepostet habe.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist der Monat, wo es Bonuszahlungen gibt.
Es ist nicht immer so hoch, ja.
Wurde ich ja teilweise geflamed, weil die Leute gesagt haben, alter hier, cringe Flex oder whatever.
Wobei ich das ehrlich gesagt nicht primär aus Flexgründen gemacht habe,
sondern weil es die Leute, gerade wenn ich auf YouTube gucke, die Videos anscheinend wahnsinnig interessiert.
Dachte ich mir, machen wir mal wieder Update, wenn ich schon kein Video Update mache.
Vielleicht war es Mini Flex, keine Ahnung.
Aber es war zumindest nicht der primäre Grund.
Zumindest ist es schon wieder outdated, weil letztens hat mein Chef zu mir gesagt, ey Max, komm mal mit, musst du dir was sagen?
Habe ich schon gesagt, hä, oje, was ist jetzt los?
Und er hat gemeint, ja, im April gibt es mehr Geld.
Ach wie, was?
Ja, sage ich nicht, nee.
Und anscheinend haben die irgendwelche neuen Tarife, ich bin ja nicht im Tarifvertrag,
Tarifvertrag, aber das Unternehmen, bei dem ich arbeite, ist in einem Tarifvertrag.
Also ich habe keinen Tarifvertrag, aber die haben einen Tarifvertrag.
Versteht man, was ich meine?
Also es gibt auch ganz viele, die sind dort, haben einen Vertrag unter den Rahmenbedingungen
vom Tarifvertrag.
Zumindest ist es so, anscheinend haben die einen neuen Tarifvertrag ausgehandelt und
da gab es jetzt mehr Kohle.
Und ich habe zwar keinen Vertrag, der sich nach dem Tarifvertrag richtet, aber die Tarifvertrag-Anpassung bekommt man auch als außertariflicher Vertragspartner, Vertragshaber.
Ja, weil, das ist eigentlich ganz logisch, weil ansonsten würde ja irgendwann derjenige im Tarifvertrag denjenigen außer dem Tarifvertrag überholen, wenn die nicht auch die Anpassung kriegen würden.
Deswegen gab es eine Anpassung von, ähm, ich weiß es nicht genau, ungefähr von 95k auf 100k.
Also es waren 94.500 zu 99.500, irgendwie sowas.
Ja, also grob von 95k auf 100k.
Und das Geile ist, ich hab, also wenn ich, Moment, wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde, ne?
Wohlgemerkt, ich arbeite ja nicht 100%.
Also von mir ist das weniger.
Und das Geile ist, ich habe das mal ausgerechnet, was das heißt.
Also erstens natürlich heißt das mehr Steuern bezahlen,
weil mehr Steuern bezahlen ja immer ganz toll ist.
Und jetzt, wenn die neue Beitragsbemessungsgrenze und sowas angehoben wird,
auch mehr für die Krankenversicherung zahlen und whatever.
Also, naja, zumindest, äh, Rentenversicherung auch, naja, zumindest habe ich das mal ausgerechnet und ich habe mal den Durchschnittsfall ausgerechnet, wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde.
und da ist mir aufgefallen, das war mir so
im Vorfeld noch gar nicht klar
und das ist auch, deckt sich
auch mit dem, was ich auf Twitter gepostet habe
Alter, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum
die mir so viel Geld überweisen
Ich
Ich mache da ein bisschen Linux-Zeug
Cloud-Gedöns
Ich programmiere das ein oder andere Tool
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, warum
die mir so viel Geld überweisen
ich meine, soll mir recht sein, ich will mich jetzt nicht
beschweren und wenn mich
einer vor die Wahl stellen würde
ähm
wenn mich einer vor die Wahl stellen würde
Max, willst du noch mehr haben oder weniger
da würde ich natürlich immer sagen, noch mehr
und ganz so schlecht
scheine ich das ja auch nicht zu machen, weil mein Chef erzählt
mir immer, die sind alle super zufrieden und so
und auch vom Projekt und alle sind alle happy
das ist schon krass, wenn man das mal mit
anderen vergleicht
die wirklich relevante Dinger machen
Ja, beispielsweise Pfleger, die sich um alte Leute kümmern und sowas. Teilweise der Witz, was die kriegen. Wo man wohl mittlerweile ganz gut verdienen muss, ist tatsächlich im Gesundheitssektor, wenn man bereit ist, wohlgemerkt, wenn man bereit ist, so, wie nennen die das, so Wildcard, weiß ich nicht, ob das so heißt, so Wildcard-Jobs zu machen.
So nach dem Motto, ey, heute braucht eine Klinik in Hamburg für zwei Wochen jemand, ey, heute braucht eine Praxis in München für zwei Wochen einen. Also wenn du bereit bist, sowas zu machen, kannst du wohl im Gesundheitswesen echt ganz gut Kohle verdienen, habe ich gelesen.
Ja, zumindest, um das jetzt nicht länger auszulehnen, ich habe das mal ausgerechnet, mit dem, mit diesem neuen Gehalt, also mit der neuen Gehaltsanpassung, ja, also irgendwie, was sind es, irgendwie 99.450 bei 100%.
prozent so das ist ja mit dem minimal bonus und sonst nix das heißt es ist das was man auf meinen
tomox das ist das was man auf jeden fall sicher kriegt also sprich egal wie schlecht man war und
egal wie wenig bonus sachen man erfüllt hat und was man alles verkackt hat darunter geht es nicht
so dann habe ich mal ausgerechnet also nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal 99 k oder 100 k dann habe ich
mal ausgerechnet, wenn ich wirklich 100%
arbeiten würde, ja,
normal Rufbereitschaft machen würde,
Zulage krieg für das
ich Rufbereitschaft mache,
plus die Bonuszahlung
im März, da wären
das bei 100%
arbeiten fast 140k.
What the fuck,
Alter?
Für Linux-Stells,
Alter.
Bisschen Proggas und Linux-Stells.
Gut, man muss aber dazu sagen, der Eigenlob stinkt, ich habe auch schon ein bisschen Ahnung davon, so ist es ja nicht.
Aber WTF, Alter.
Wir suchen gerade nur Junior-Leute.
Witzigerweise, keiner sucht Juniors, wir suchen Juniors.
Wir suchen einen Junior-Storage-Admin.
Und ich glaube, wir suchen auch noch einen...
Ich glaube, einen Netzwerk-Admin suchen wir auch noch, der sich mit so Cross-Switch-Kram und Zeug auskennt.
Tomox, danke schön für den Sub.
Gar nicht gesehen.
Pog-Subscription.
Ich glaube, es wird mal wieder Zeit für so ein Update-Video,
weil das haben die Leute immer richtig, richtig gerne
entscheidend geguckt, ja.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Videos zugemacht, so
Gehaltsentwicklung, und die hatten
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 70k Aufrufe oder so.
Aber, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind,
YouTube-Videos, keck, wait, Alter.
So, jetzt haben wir erstmal Update, und dann machen wir
Reboot.
Das ist aber auch nicht, nicht,
nicht, äh, na gut, man muss
aber man muss halt sagen es ist frankfurt es ist finanzbranche da gibt es halt auch da gab es mal
beim spiegel so eine statistik das ist das wo am meisten bezahlen ich glaube am meisten wird
bezahlt bei der bank am zweitmeisten wird bezahlt bei der versicherung am drittmeisten wird glaube
ich bei autoherstellern bezahlt und dann irgendwie chemie und sowas also ich habe halt auch schon
echt glück frankfurt finanzbranche das ist das wohl statistisch gesehen am meisten bezahlt wird
Ja gut, das, natürlich, natürlich zählt das bei mir rein.
Ich mache den Kram ja schon seit 2005 oder so.
20 Jahre.
20 Jahre mache ich das schon.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Berufserfahrung, also ich will mich jetzt da nicht schlechter machen oder so, ja, aber muss man auch sagen, Berufserfahrung, ganz ehrlich, ist overrated.
Bin ich der Meinung.
Also ja, Erfahrung an sich ist nicht overrated, aber ob jetzt, also ganz ehrlich, ich sehe es ab einer gewissen Anzahl bei manchen Leuten sogar eher als Nachteil.
Ja, du hast Leute, die machen seit 30 Jahren oder 40 Jahren machen den Kram, haben früher Solaris administriert und erzählen dir jedes Mal, ach bei Solaris hätt's das nicht gegeben, Linux ist doch ein Amateursystem, Solaris war das Beste und unter Solaris hätt's das so nicht gegeben.
Das bringt keinem was, dass die Leute 40 Jahre Berufserfahrung haben. Die labern dir das Ohr ab von Solaris oder irgendeinem anderen Scheiß, was nichts mit der aktuellen Realität zu tun hat und sobald sie irgendwie was, äh, mal ein Git machen müssen oder, ähm, irgendwie mal was in der Cloud zusammen klicken müssen oder so, sind die komplett planlos.
die sind planloser als jeder Junior,
weil die Junior-Leute wollen ja
sogar noch was lernen. Die Leute, die
20 Jahre davon Solaris
gemacht haben, die wollen das neue Zeug ja nicht.
Die lehnen das ja innerlich ab.
Die sagen ja, Solaris war quasi die Krone
der Schöpfung und alles danach ist halt
super für den Arsch.
So, und
ganz ehrlich, in dem Fall
ist Berufserfahrung eher
von Nachteil als von Vorteil. Also ich bin der Meinung,
also Berufserfahrung
ist teilweise schon sehr overrated.
Schweiz.
Schweiz muss generell gut sein.
Also, wie gesagt, bei uns verdient man ja ganz gut.
Und trotzdem ist einer in die Schweiz abgewandert.
Da gibt es dann halt noch mehr.
BlackHD,
danke schön für den Sub.
57 Jahre.
Pog.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das stimmt schon.
Also es gibt schon Leute, die sind da echt nervig
Was?
I quit my GitHub job because I
break software. Ja Moment, da geht's
doch um das, was bei GitHub
demletzt gewesen ist, oder?
Wobei, das ist schon im April, das kann eigentlich noch gar nicht sein
Ach, guck mal!
Der hat bei GitHub gearbeitet, oder was?
Okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant
Steuern, ja, kann auch sein
Letztendlich ist ja auch egal
Der hat unterm Strich deutlich mehr Kohle bekommen
Deswegen hat er es gemacht, denke ich mal
Max, oder auch
Chat mal eine Frage, jemand eine Idee, wo man die ganzen
Kram rund um DNS lernen kann
Was meinst du? Also, DNS ist so ein Ding. DNS an sich, so die Basic-Sachen ist eigentlich äußerst simpel. Die Details ist obskure Sache, die sich vor 50 Jahren mal ausgedacht wurde.
So auch mit irgendwelchen Zonenreplikationen und was der Unterschied ist zwischen, ähm, äh, was gibt's da, Resolver und, und, Authorative und, ach, keine Ahnung.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ich hab das bis heute noch nicht alles hundertprozentig gecheckt.
Ja, das bringt dir aber auch nicht die richtigen Hardcore-Daten.
sachen bei aber wie gesagt so die die kompletten details und wie das alles
also habe ich bei dns auch nicht gecheckt also ich kann ja schon grob
natürlich sagen was dns macht ich kann auch dns server mit anbauen oder so oder
mit mit dns maß das ist das ist kein problem das kann ich alles machen aber
aber so die die feinen unterschiede also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise bei
irgendeinem größeren provider arbeiten würde und müsste mich darum die
irgendwelche route dns server oder so kümmern da wird wahrscheinlich voll
abkacken aber im zweifelsfall im zweifelsfall wie
gesagt youtube tutorial sind immer gut ja da gibt es auch für vieles sehr gute
videos bestimmt bestimmt für dns stelle es auch immer von glaube ich glaube ich
mal nicht dass ich jetzt bis jetzt gesehen hatte
wir haben jemand bei uns im team der nimmt die sachen immer ganz super genau
und da gibt es dann teilweise diskussionen
du denkst du also alter ich halte nach nach keine ahnung fünf minuten im kopf
ab und es geht dann noch 30 Minuten länger.
Ja, das ist so jemand, was weiß ich, gehen wir mal von aus,
gehen wir mal von aus, das ist Daily und ich würde erzählen,
ja übrigens in dem und dem Produkt, da haben wir jetzt auch ein Software-Update gemacht,
die haben da ein paar Sachen verbessert und jetzt ist es viel schneller.
So, irgendwie sowas.
Ja, stellt euch mal vor, ich hätte es gesagt und dann würde diese Person dann wahrscheinlich einhaken
und Sachen. Naja, ob das eine
Verbesserung ist, steht mal
auf dem anderen Blatt. Ich würde es einfach
nur Weiterentwicklung bezeichnen.
So Dinger sagt er dann.
Dann gucken sich alle immer an
und wir denken uns,
okay, und jetzt?
So komplett sinnlose
Dinger kommen da immer.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
Er hat glaube ich jeder schon mal gehabt.
Dann so super korrekt nehmen
und immer aus irgendwelchen Gründen
was zu sagen müssen, auch wenn es gar nichts bringt.
Es geht doch gar nicht darum.
Ich verstehe, so hundertprozentig verstanden
habe ich es auch noch nicht.
Warum das da immer kommt.
Aber es ist teilweise Art.
Es sieht echt aus.
Wir diskutieren da teilweise eine halbe Stunde um so Kleinkram immer.
Das ist teilweise echt anstrengend.
Also man muss ja auch in der Fairness halber sagen, der hat ja auch schon manchmal recht, so ist das nicht.
Aber oftmals ist es einfach nur echt nervig.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich Updates gemacht?
Ja, Update, nice
So, jetzt machen wir noch Package-Updates
Chatterino muss geupdatet werden, ganz wichtig
Mir läuft die Nase, wartet mal kurz
So
Zack, yes
Okay, DNS-Seq habe ich auch keine Ahnung von
Stimmt, das gehört ja heute zu DNS mit
Oh nee, Reboot ist ja angesagt
Okay
Dann gucken wir nochmal kurz, was die Jetbrains Sachen machen
Ob es da ein Update gibt
Check for Updates
PyCharm Rider wird geupdatet
Okay, Update, bam
Und dann Reboot
Welche Distro ist das?
Cash.js. Archlinux ist da unter da.
Pac-Man ist zum updaten.
Und Ye ist ein
Our-Rapper.
Also sowas wie Paru
oder früher
gab es noch Trizen.
Trizen, Alter. Trizen. Gibt es das immer noch?
Das war in Pearl und ganz eklig.
Trizen, genau.
Das ist ein
Pac-Man-Rapper and Our-Helper.
written in go
nee
das ist ein Package Manager für
Arch User Repos
Arch User Repos ist
du hast die Möglichkeit unter Arch
Pakete zu installieren, die nicht in den offiziellen
Paketquellen drin sind, das besteht
dann in der Regel einfach nur aus einem Build Script
und
das war's
das Build Script lädt dann Sachen runter
oder lädt Source Code runter und kompiliert das und sowas
und über das Hour kannst du quasi diese Custom Build Scripts abrufen und ausführen.
Da kannst du dann halt Sachen installieren, die nicht in den offiziellen Repos drin sind.
Wobei man auch mal wirklich sagen muss,
bei CacheOS ist sehr viel dabei, was beim nackten Arch-Dino nicht dabei ist
und man hat deutlich weniger Pakete, die man über das Arch-User-Repo installieren muss.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was ich installiert habe, ist Chatterino, was ich hier über das Arch-User-Repo installiert habe.
Okay.
Du meinst, ach ja, das war ja auch ein größeres Thema.
Ja, ja, das kenne ich.
Das habe ich auch auf Twitter gepostet, dass es letzte Woche eine Sicherheitslücke gab für alle Linux-Systeme, also für die meisten, sagen wir mal, für die meisten, okay?
für die meisten Linux-Distributionen
seit 2017.
Also Red Hat 8 ist betroffen,
Red Hat 9 ist betroffen,
Red Hat 10 ist betroffen.
Copy-Fail, genau.
Ja.
Und da konntest du relativ einfach
root werden.
Du brauchst aber,
und deswegen ist es keine super krass
mega heftige Sicherheitslücke,
du brauchst aber vorher ein lokales Login.
Ja.
Oder zumindest die Möglichkeit, lokal was auszuführen.
Und das ist jetzt ja bei den meisten Servern erstmal nicht der Fall.
Also wenn du schon Login hast, dann hast du ja meistens noch irgendwas mit dem Anbieter zu tun.
Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem eine kritische Sache.
Ja, das habe ich mir angeguckt.
Ich habe das sogar auf der Arbeit an meinen Chef weitergeschickt.
gleich morgen, ich hab das morgens
auf dem Klo auf Reddit
gelesen.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, oh Leute,
ähm, das
sieht aber schlecht aus.
Da hab ich das bei uns im Teams-Channel geschrieben
und irgendjemand meinte, das wär doch nur
AI-Slob,
weil die Webseite so
AI-generated aussieht.
Ups, jetzt bin ich mit dem Stuhl auf
mein Kabel gefahren.
Ja, copy.fail.
das würde so ein slob aussehen und er glaubt nicht dass es echt ist die seite ist halt irgendwie generiert
Aber
ich habe da noch ein bisschen weiter geht's kalt das war echt mittlerweile weiß man es ja auch
und dann habe ich meinem chef weiter geschickt und habe ihm auch noch den link zum red bug tracker geschickt hier
kann man kurz gucken cv
Bug zilla oder
Red hat
Ja, und da sieht man hier, was alles von Red Hat betroffen ist.
Das hatte ich auch meinem Chef weitergeschickt, hier unten das Ding.
Hier, Red Hat 8, Red Hat 9 und Red Hat 10 ist betroffen.
Die Uralt-Distributionen mit sonst was können.
Red Hat 6 und 7 sind nicht mal betroffen.
Aber da hast du andere Probleme wahrscheinlich, wenn du auf den Dinger noch hängst, ne?
Aber ansonsten ist hier mehr oder weniger alles effected.
Und das haben die dann auch weitergeleitet an unsere Security-Leute und die haben irgendeine Einschätzung dann geschrieben und whatever.
Es ging dann seinen Gang.
Zumindest wir mussten nicht Emergency patchen, weil man gesagt hat, bei uns ist das nicht so wild, weil es lokales Login voraussetzt.
Ist es inzwischen gepatcht?
Ich glaube dem Chat einfach mal, ich habe es nicht näher verfolgt.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das geschrieben habe, standen Patches noch aus.
Die letzten Tage jetzt, Freitag und Samstag, habe ich das Ganze nicht mehr verfolgt, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ich denke mal, es wäre schon arm, wenn das mittlerweile nicht gepatcht ist, weil für was bezahlt man hier Red Hat?
Also, das wird ziemlich sicher mittlerweile gepatcht sein.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es auf Debian...
Wir können ja mal kurz gucken.
Äh, Debian?
Gucken wir doch mal.
Okay, Bullseye ist betroffen, Bookworm ist betroffen, Trixie ist betroffen.
Na gut, das habe ich mir schon auch gedacht.
Okay, fixed.
Ja, fixed, fixed, fixed.
Also, das ist bei dem hier auch behoben mittlerweile.
Hätte mich auch gewundert, wenn die da wirklich länger alten.
Einen halben Tag oder einen Tag brauchen bei solchen Dingern.
Da sind die immer relativ geschwind.
Debian E-Beste.
Ich mache mir bei Debian so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Die haben ja letztens so einen Blogpost rausgehauen, dass sie Nachwuchsprobleme haben mit Leuten, die Sachen maintainen wollen.
Ich hoffe, das wird nicht noch schlimmer.
ich hoffe, dass vielleicht auch mal ein paar Unternehmen
jetzt sagen, ey, wir stellen mal ein paar Leute
für Debian ab, die sich da drum kümmern,
weil es wäre schon scheiße,
wenn Debian immer
ja,
so immer weiter in der
Versenkung verschwinden würde, weil für mich ist
Debian beste, beste Distro, die es gibt
für Server, ja.
Auf der Arbeit verwenden wir Red Hat, weil
wir gerne massig Lizenzgebühren
bezahlen, aber für
mich privat und für alles andere,
wo ich nicht bezahlt werde für
Debian Beste.
Ubuntu benutze ich gar nicht mehr.
Ich war ja früher richtig großer
Ubuntu-Fan. Auch Ubuntu-Server.
Ich habe auch noch mal eine Weile Ubuntu auf dem Desktop verwendet.
Aber seit
Jahren schon
verwende ich eigentlich kein Ubuntu mehr.
Ich kann euch gar nicht so diesen
einen Punkt sagen, wo ich
gesagt habe alter ubuntu auf keinen fall mehr also ich weiß es war so eine
mischung aus als am anfang gab es nett plan nett plan ist nett plan dann macht
man mit jammer hier jammer config für seine netzwerk interfaces ich weiß es
hat seine fans chat chat haben wir nett planen im chat ich bin euch nicht böse
wenn ihr netplan mögt gibt es gibt es netplan enjoyer heute netplan mögen also damit dass das
hat ja ubuntu hier eingeführt da muss man seine netzwerk interfaces letztendlich mit so einer
komischen jammel datei konfigurieren das hat mir schon überhaupt nicht gefallen das war so eines
der ersten punkt wo ich gesagt habe da habe ich eigentlich keinen bock drauf also das mit
features bei ubuntu gehört nähe habe ich nicht was denn was erstmalig und das nächste und das
nächste war dass sie dann irgendwann angefangen haben bestimmte pakete die du über abt installiert
hast wurden gar nicht wirklich über abt in dem sinn installiert als paket sondern es wurde
snap installierten aus dem snap store wurde das paket runtergeladen das fand ich auch abfuck so
So, und diese zwei Sachen zusammen haben mehr oder weniger so über ein paar Monate dazu geführt,
dass ich irgendwann einfach kein Ubuntu mehr installiert habe.
Und habe mir gedacht, warum soll ich mich mit Ubuntu rumquälen, wenn ich doch auch einfach Debian nehmen kann.
Oder wieder einfach Debian nehmen kann.
Also habe ich wieder Debian genommen und mache seitdem wieder alles mit Debian.
Wilder Igel, Dankeschön.
Exzellente Subscription
Snap hat mega genervt
Hat? Nervt immer noch
Oder gibt es das mittlerweile nicht mehr
Ne das gibt es bestimmt immer noch
Ubuntu AI Features
Oh come on
Canonical is ramping up AI in Ubuntu
This year
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet
die haben sich alle gedacht endlich endlich features in kubo die leute haben schon haben
schon quasi gesagt oh ne leute und hat keine features wir können nur bunte nicht mal verwenden
aber jetzt alles gut man hat ja bei microsoft gesehen wie beliebt das ist features mit windows
zu wandeln.
Das sagen die auch nur,
weil die den ganzen Shitstorm
bei Microsoft mitbekommen haben.
Microsoft
Co-Pilot
Ubuntu
Also was
machen sie denn?
von die weiße models kann man besser verwenden okay das buchstab an sachen wie text to speech
und spiel speech to text ok explicit features new editions power by a generative text writing
documents automated file manager will ich wirklich automated file management per ki machen
Auto-Delete
Das beste Beispiel dafür
Was KI sich teilweise für ein Shit ausdenkt
Ist
Ich hab doch hier letztens was gepost
Okay
Ich hab doch hier letztens was
Ich meine nicht die Cuts
Ich hab doch hier letztens was gepostet
Wo KI sich auch was zurecht halluziniert hat
Wartet mal
Ja
Hat sich die
Hat sich die KI bei mir zurecht
Halluziniert
Vorgeschlagen
Nie blind CD'n
Dafür
dir also einfach slash rm-rf also nur mal zur erklärung ja das ist eine das ist eine function
in bash und dollar eins ist das erste argument was du dieser function übergibt also wenn ich
die jetzt so aufrufen würde work dir blubb so wir können das ja mal machen hier work dir so echo
Dollar 1, okay? So.
Wenn ich jetzt Work dir aufrufe,
Keckel, dann echo der Keckel, weil
Dollar 1 Keckel ist. Aber,
warte mal, wir müssen dies mal anders definieren.
Ähm, Slash, machen wir Slash
Keckel, okay? So, Slash Keckel.
So. Was passiert
denn jetzt, wenn ich die hier aufrufe?
Ohne Argument. Fällt euch
da was auf?
dann ist es einfach nur slash und genau das passiert hier auch also sprich wenn ich diese
das ist das ist so dämlich ja wenn ich den für die funktion hier aufrufe ohne argument
lösche ich einfach meine gesamte disk nur das ist streng genommen falsch ich lösche alles unterhalb
von einem Brutverzeichnis.
Also.
The fuck?
Chat-GPT.
Also so gedöhnt, was sich das da teilweise
zurechtbastelt.
Warum dann eine lokale Wache?
Ja, ich hab...
Ja, ja, gut, dass er hier zweimal
dir verwenden kann, anstatt...
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er denkt, es ist lesbarer.
Tja, so sieht's aus.
Also will ich wirklich KI-gesteuertes File-Management machen?
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob ich das wirklich will.
Der Steam...
Doch, Steam hatte so einen ähnlichen Bug.
Steam hat auch mal...
Ich glaube, das Heimatverzeichnis gelöscht.
Wenn man die falschen Dinge angeklickt hat.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Oder war das nicht der Steam-Aninstaller?
Irgendwas?
Zumindest hatte Steam auch diesen Bug.
Ah, okay, die Sachen kommen dann über den Snap Store.
Okay, das sind ja schon mal zwei Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen.
Mehr KI-Features und Snap Store.
Aber das betrifft hoffentlich nur Ubuntu Desktop, nicht Ubuntu Server.
Und selbst wenn es Ubuntu Server betrifft, ist mir auch egal, weil ich verwende keinen Ubuntu Server mehr.
Don't expect a global AI kill switch if you don't use them.
Na geil, man kann es doch nicht mal abschalten.
It would be complex to implement.
Laber.
Wenn man das von Anfang an haben möchte und das einbaut, ist das gar kein Problem.
Ganz ehrlich, es ist jetzt nicht so, als hat da irgendjemand danach gefragt, oder?
Ja gut, Mozilla hat es ja auch verkackt.
Ey, Mozilla, was Mozilla treibt, habe ich eh keine Ahnung, was die die letzten Jahre so machen.
außer komplett gefühlt an ihrer Userbase vorbei entwickeln.
Ich weiß noch, wo sie vor zwei Jahren oder so erzählt haben,
Firefox wird jetzt ein AI-First-Browser.
Und alle damals schon Hände über dem Kopf zusammengeschlagen,
Alter, Mozilla, gehen uns nicht auf den Sack.
Aber man sieht das bei Microsoft, wisst ihr?
Ich glaube bei vielen Unternehmen ist das ähnlich wie bei Microsoft
Vielleicht nicht ganz so krass ausgeprägt, aber ähnlich
Die ganzen CEOs sind voll auf dem AI-Hype
Und klopfen sich auch immer schön gegenseitig beim Golfspielen oder so auf die Schulter
Wie geil sie sind und was sie tolles AI-mäßig gemacht haben
Und wollen sich da überbieten und was noch, hast du nicht gesehen
Und denken halt, das ist das Einzige, was man machen muss
zumindest werden dann die leute eingeschworen auf ki guckt euch an bei
microsoft bei microsoft ging sogar so weit dass der microsoft chef interne
e-mail rum geschrieben hat in der sinngemäß so was drin stand wie wer
keinen bock auf ki hat kann abhauen mal gucken ob wir das finden microsoft ceo
internal mail keine ahnung ob man das auch findet
mandatory shift towards artificial intelligence
er ist optional bla bla bla also
zumindest sinngemäß stand da mehrfach drinnen
Wer keinen Bock auf KI hat, kann abhauen.
So, und jetzt mal ganz im Ernst.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich hab's, glaube ich, schon ein paar Mal gesagt,
aber stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid im Team, das Teams entwickelt
oder Windows entwickelt oder GitHub entwickelt oder whatever.
Ja, ihr seid in irgendeinem Team dort.
So, und ihr seid so der Hardcore-Karriere-Crinder.
Und jetzt sagt man, ey Leute, wir bauen KI in Notepad ein.
Jetzt habt ihr zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder ihr sagt, Leute, seid ihr euch wirklich sicher, dass wir das machen sollten?
Erstens bietet das potenziell Angriffsfläche, wo wir vorher keins hatten.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute das haben wollen.
Wenn man sich mal den ganzen Backlash anguckt, den es die letzten Monate über so gegeben hat.
Oder ihr sagt, jawohl Chef, beste Idee ever.
Ich bin vollkommen on board mit deiner Vision.
Beste hier und ich habe noch ein paar Vorschläge
Wir können KI auch noch in Paint einbauen
Und in die Taskleiste einbauen
Ich bin der Erste der KI
Was wird ein Karriere-Criner machen
Wenn er weiß
Sein Chef steht komplett auf KI
Der wird ins gleiche Horn blasen
Und ich glaube
Das ist das, was bei ganz vielen Unternehmen passiert
Die CEOs stehen übelst auf KI-Kram
Und die Leute
Die da Karriere machen wollen
Beziehungsweise ja eigentlich
Keine Probleme haben wollen
machen das halt.
Und das ist auch vollkommen verständlich.
Mal angenommen,
unser IT-Chef
oder so, würde auf der Arbeit
jetzt sagen, ey, ab morgen
verwenden wir nur noch
sagt mal irgendwas
Blödes.
Ab morgen
verwenden wir nur noch
Bitbucket.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Hat es dann wirklich Sinn?
Also jetzt überlegt euch mal.
Also es geht jetzt nicht darum, was ich persönlich machen würde.
Ja.
Ich persönlich würde sagen, überlegt euch mal, ob die Umstellung sich lohnt.
Aber das wäre es dann auch.
Mehr würde ich da auch gar nicht zu sagen.
Weil ich denke mir ganz ehrlich, wenn die das haben wollen.
Was ist besser für einen?
Um mal ganz rational überlegt.
Also mal angenommen, ihr habt alles super eingestellt, ihr verwendet lokal GitLab und es funktioniert alles wunderbar und euer Chef war auf irgendeinem Atlassian Workshop oder so und kommt jetzt um die Ecke und sagt, Leute, wir verwenden jetzt nur noch Bitbucket. Ja, da kann man schon mal sagen, überlegt euch mal, ob das so sinnvoll ist, das jetzt alles umzustellen und das wird wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Weile dauern, bis das alles wieder so gut funktioniert.
So, und dann sagen die, nee, unsere Vision ist, wir machen jetzt nur noch Bitbucket.
Was ist für euch unterm Strich besser?
Ihr meckert zwei Jahre lang während der kompletten Umstellung rum, wie kacke Bitbucket ist und wie geil GitLab ist und ihr findet das richtig beschissen und ihr wollt das nicht machen.
Oder ihr sagt vielleicht einmal, dass ihr es keine für eine gute Idee haltet und blast dann einfach ins gleiche Horn danach.
Was ist unterm Strich für eure Karriere, für euer Gehalt, für euren Gemütszustand besser?
Ganz ehrlich, das Zweite wahrscheinlich.
Zu sagen, ey Leute, ich hab's euch einmal gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es so eine gute Idee ist,
aber wenn ihr das wirklich machen wollt, dann mach ich damit.
Weil was bleibt euch denn anders übrig?
Das wird jetzt keiner sagen, ey guck mal hier.
Der Max, der mag das nicht.
Deswegen stelle ich jetzt meine ganze Vision dafür um.
Das ist kein IT-Chef, CEO oder so, der wird das sagen.
Die sagen, wir wollen das haben.
Und wer da nicht mitmacht, der soll sich halt verpissen.
Also bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig, wie entweder zu sagen,
okay, das geht so krass gegen das, was ich machen will.
Ich hau ab oder ich mach mit.
Also bei Bitbucket würde ich mitmachen.
Wenn die jetzt sagen würden, Max, ab morgen verwenden wir kein Linux mehr,
sondern nur noch Windows, dann würde ich sagen,
nee, das mache ich nicht mit, da haue ich ab.
Muss man halt immer gucken.
Aber ansonsten, es hat doch keinen Sinn,
es hat doch keinen Sinn,
bei irgendeinem Projekt zwei Jahre
lang nur rumzumeckern.
Ja, es, das, das,
das bringt euch nix.
Man kann am Anfang mal drauf hinweisen,
oder an wichtigen Stellen darauf hinweisen,
dass manche Sachen vielleicht keine so gute Idee sind.
Vielleicht hat man sogar noch einen Vorschlag,
wie man es besser machen könnte.
Aber ansonsten, keiner mag Leute,
die zwei Jahre am Stück über irgendwas Neues nur meckern.
Ganz ehrlich, man muss was nicht persönlich geil finden,
um es auf der Arbeit machen zu können.
Wir haben auch ganz viele Tools,
die ich persönlich nicht geil finde,
die aber halt gesetzt sind.
Also klicke ich da halt einmal im halben Jahr irgendwas durch und reg mich ein bisschen auf bei. Ja, meinetwegen. Muss ich es aber jedes Mal an die große Glocke hängen? So nach dem Motto, boah, ey, wieder dieses Tool, eine große Rundmail schreiben, das Tool ist so scheiße, können wir das endlich? Ne, muss ich nicht, weil es ändert nichts.
Naja, so
Und ich glaube, so läuft das
So läuft das halt bei dieser ganzen KI-Geschichte auch
Die CEO-Leute sind da so drauf fokussiert
Und letztendlich
Wird dann halt einfach mitgezogen
Weil was sollen die Leute denn sonst machen
Ja, die können am Anfang sagen, vielleicht mal
Ah ne, keine so gute Idee
Und gerade die, die super Karriere machen wollen
Die werden instant ins gleiche Horn blasen
Und erzählen
Oh, krass, alter CEO
welche vision ich bin so erleuchtet durch diese vision das ist ja das geilste
ever und ich bin da voll on board dabei und ich gebe jetzt alles die werden
dann rumschleim es fuck und deswegen bauen die alle ki ein deswegen baut
mozilla sagt sie bauen firefox zu einem browser um und microsoft macht microsoft
365 Copilot-Taskleiste
und was es nicht alles gibt.
Naja.
Ganz ehrlich,
dass Ubuntu jetzt
AI-Features hat, mich wundert sogar,
dass es jetzt erst der Fall ist.
Weil jetzt ist der Trend,
finde ich, schon fast absehbar,
dass die Leute,
wie nennen sie das immer im englischsprachigen Raum, AI-Fatigue, also so Erschöpfung, KI-Erschöpfung haben.
Die wollen eigentlich davon gar nichts mehr wissen.
Also die sind jetzt ein bisschen spät bei Canonical.
Jetzt ist nämlich schon der Zug, finde ich, ein bisschen abgefahren, damit groß Werbung machen zu können.
Es ist zur Zeit eher so, also da ist vielleicht der irgendwie bei denen nicht so ganz am Puls der Zeit.
jetzt ist es doch aktuell eher so sobald eine irgendwelche großen ki features
ankündigt rollen die leute mit den augen und sagt alter gehen wir bloß weg
vorher hätten das vor zwei jahren gemacht das würde was anderes aber jetzt
ist ein bisschen spät
auf einmal musste alles xml sein das weiß ich nicht warum also ich kann mich
noch daran erinnern dass die früher früher stand microsoft sie auf xml da
gab es doch auch mal dieses ding habe ich selbst nie verwendet aber manche
unternehmen benutzen das doch heute noch wie heißt das windows wcf oder hieß es
nicht so wcf windows communication foundation xml
Ja.
Genau das hier.
Genau, ja.
Und WPF, Maui, Avalonia und die benutzen ja auch so ein XML-Dialekt.
Das ist übrigens, warte mal.
Das ist übrigens das, was mich auch daran abschreckt.
Ihr wisst doch, ich bin großer C-Sharp und .NET-Fan eigentlich.
Obwohl ich jetzt nicht der größte Microsoft-Fan bin, aber da machen sie echt gute Sachen.
Aber Maui ist für den Arsch.
Avalonia ist besser, aber ich mag einfach Gui per XAML nicht.
Das Schöne ist, bei Avalonia gibt es ja mittlerweile...
Ich hoffe, die haben da Examples zu.
Bei Avalonia gibt es ja mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, das auch programmatisch zu lösen.
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Was sehen wir denn jetzt hier?
Drawing.
Rekt Painter.
Get rekt.
Ähm.
Die haben jetzt auch die Möglichkeit
Bei Avalonia
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man das hier
Showcase vielleicht
Die haben die Möglichkeit
Ich hab das letztens erst gesehen
Bei Avalonia
Dass man das auch programmatisch macht
Ohne XAML
Oder war das bei UNO
Create your first project
Guck mal, super, Avalonia
Without Xamel
Hier, hier, genau
Genau
Hier, du kannst das
mittlerweile in Avalonia
auch alles programmatisch
machen. Du brauchst kein Xemel mehr.
Ob es auf lange Sicht sinnvoll
ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe noch
nichts Großartiges in Avalonia gemacht.
Ich glaube, das Einzige,
das Einzige, was wir in Avalonia
gemacht haben,
wir haben mal
was in Avalonia gemacht.
Ist aber schon eine ganze
Weile her.
Äh, das ist von...
2023, okay.
Ah, ja, ja.
App.
Okay, Leute
Wir haben die beste App aller Zeiten gebaut
In Avalonia
Ja, aber das haben wir auch mit XAML gemacht
Ja, aber da sieht man noch
Dass Microsoft wohl sehr auf XAML stand
zur damaligen Zeit.
Möglich, ja.
damals im chat dieselben leute ja sie
ist doch schön dass so viele immer und
immer wieder am start sind
ich kenne auch ich mich freut das immer
wenn ich leute im chat sehe ich kenne
ich freue mich auch wenn ich leute im
chat sehe die ich nicht kenne
ich finde immer cool wenn man ein paar
leute sieht wo man denkt der mario xcb
ist wieder am Start.
Habt ihr schon über den Marathon-Weltrekord
gesprochen? Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich kann da auch nicht allzu viel
beitragen, aber ich kann euch sagen, es gab
einen neuen Marathon-Weltrekord.
1 Stunde 59 und 30 Sekunden.
Das sind, glaube ich, knapp
50 Sekunden oder so.
Oder 45 Sekunden oder irgendwie sowas.
Unter dem alten Weltrekord.
Das ist extrem schnell
gewesen. Extrem schnell. Und jetzt
nur mal als Beispiel, das ist komplett
unmenschlich, die Leute. Also wirklich, die sind
einfach
unglaublich, ja.
Der zweite,
genau, die ersten drei,
das war ja das Geile, das war glaube ich der London Marathon,
die ersten drei beim London
Marathon sind schneller gelaufen als der
Weltrekord. So.
Zwei davon unter zwei Stunden.
Bisher hat man immer gesagt, zwei Stunden ist so die
magische Grenze, ja.
Der dritte auch, zwei Stunden,
11 oder irgendwie sowas.
So, sag ich gleich was zu.
Ich versuche euch das mal kurz zu erklären, wie krass diese Leute sind.
Ich kann...
Also...
Die rennen im Durchschnitt ungefähr einen 2,50er Pace pro Kilometer.
Das heißt, 2 Minuten 50 pro Kilometer. Ich kann, ich kann, wenn ich frisch bin, ich kann 5 Kilometer rennen mit im Durchschnitt pro Kilometer 5 Minuten 40.
Das ist kein Ding, das kriege ich hin. Das ist aber schon anstrengend. Ich kann auch schneller rennen, aber das ist schon anstrengend.
Also ich renne 5 Kilometer, 45 und das ist schon anstrengend.
Und die rennen doppelt so schnell wie ich.
Doppelt so schnell.
Knapp über 40 Kilometer.
Und das sind KMH, irgendwas um 20 KMH.
Irgendwas ungefähr um 20 KMH sind das, glaube ich.
Im Durchschnitt über 40 Kilometer.
20 KMH rennen.
5K in wie lange?
Äh, ich hab nicht gesagt, wie lange.
Ich hab gesagt, also wenn ich
5 Kilometer lang
5 Minuten 40
pro Kilometer renne,
äh, 5 Minuten 40 pro Kilometer
renne, dann
ist das anstrengend.
So, und die rennen
2 Minuten 50.
Die rennen
2 Minuten 50 pro Kilometer.
Über 40 Kilometer. Das sind
ungefähr 20 kmh.
Bisschen mehr.
Gucken wir mal. Warte mal.
Marathon World Record
kmh. Suchen wir mal danach.
21,2
Leute.
kmh.
Das ist schneller, als die meisten Leute auf dem Fahrrad fahren.
Also die meisten Leute, die fahren...
Ich meine jetzt da die Leute, die so hobbymäßig zum Einkaufen und so fahren.
Die fahren deutlich langsamer als 21,2 kmh.
Ja, jemand, der ordentlich reintritt und ein ordentliches Fahrrad hat, der fährt schneller als 21 kmh.
Aber die meisten Leute, die ihr so mit dem Fahrrad rumfahren seht, die fahren deutlich langsamer als 21,2 kmh.
Könntest du das überhaupt laufen? Ne.
Also ich könnte das vielleicht, ich könnte das vielleicht einen 100 Meter Sprint machen oder so.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal das
Das ist super krass, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen
Leute, wenn man
Als ich selbst noch nicht regelmäßig gelaufen bin
Hab ich mir diese Weltrekordsachen immer angeguckt
Auch bei den Olympischen Spielen immer angeguckt
Und mir so gedacht
Ah ja, die sind schon schnell
Sonst wären sie ja nicht die Besten der Welt
Die sind schon schnell
Ähm
Mittlerweile
nachdem ich regelmäßig selbst laufen gehe,
ist mein Verständnis
dafür gewachsen, wie unerreichbar
schnell das eigentlich ist.
Das war für den Zweiten auch der erste
Marathon.
Man ist da übrigens, also falls es euch
ähnlich geht, ihr seid da nicht alleine.
Es gab eine Umfrage
in England
bei den letzten
Olympischen Spielen.
Gab es eine Umfrage
also an die englische Bevölkerung,
ob sie denken,
dass wenn sie jetzt anfangen zu trainieren,
sie bei den nächsten Olympischen Spielen auch starten könnten.
Und da hat ein nicht unerheblicher Teil
gesagt, ja klar,
wenn ich jetzt anfange zu trainieren, kein Problem,
da kann ich bei den nächsten Olympischen Spielen mitmachen.
So eine Aussage kann halt nur kommen von jemand, der absolut keine Ahnung hat und selbst noch nie was in der Richtung gemacht hat.
Mitmachen heißt auch, du musst dich qualifizieren.
Im Leben nicht.
Warte mal.
Ja, Umfrage England.
Mal gucken, ob ich das finde.
Hier, hier.
Guck mal.
27% der Britinnen und Briten
trauen sich Olympiateilnahme zu.
Eine Umfrage zu verholfen,
kann sich das in Großbritannien gut jeder
und jeder Vierte vorstellen, besonders in Sport
ohne viel Bewegung.
Das viele Menschen mit
zur Selbstüberschätzung neigen, ist bekannt und verlegt.
Ja.
Ach, guck mal, das gibt es ja sogar sortiert
nach, nach, ähm,
nach Sportart.
Archery.
Im Leben nicht, Leute.
Selbst sowas ohne Bewegung.
Das ist...
Ich selbst habe noch nie Bogen geschossen, ja.
Aber ich habe jetzt erkannt, seitdem ich selbst rennen gehe und Fahrrad fahren gehe,
wie von welchem anderen Planet die Leute sind, die bei solchen Veranstaltungen teilnehmen.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass das bei Bogenschießen und anderen Sachen ähnliches Skill-Level sein wird, ja.
100 Meter Sprint would definitely qualify.
Okay, immerhin, immerhin, ne, immerhin sagen...
Fuck.
Immerhin sagen sechs Leute, 100 Meter Sprint würden sie, wenn sie jetzt trainieren würden,
würden dann nächstes Jahr auf jeden Fall, in vier Jahren auf jeden Fall bei den Olympischen Spielen dabei sein.
Das ist, das ist, das ist, das sind sechs Prozent.
Die haben ja 100 Leute gefragt, oder?
Ja.
Leute, 6%.
6%.
Das ist komplett...
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Badminton.
Okay, dann würden sogar 10% sagen, sie schaffen das.
Road Racing, 6%.
Ähm...
Cycling.
Fußball.
Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, machen tatsächlich noch...
Moment, ist Football wirklich...
Doch, in England ist Football Soccer, oder?
Football ist in England Fußball.
Nur bei den Amis ist Football nicht Fußball.
Golf, Alter.
Golf ist auch super krass.
Ich hab mal probiert von so einer Driving Range...
...ein paar Bälle zu hauen.
sogar einfach nur draufhauen ist nicht einfach.
Rudern.
Rudern ist auch brutal.
Naja.
Zumindest sieht man,
die Leute neigen dazu,
sich doch
ganz schön selbst zu überschätzen.
6%
Das ist so geil.
Die Leute denken ernsthaft, dass sie das...
Na gut, aber ganz ehrlich, ich kann es ja den Leuten
noch nicht mal übel nehmen.
Dass ich mich qualifiziert hätte,
hätte ich früher nicht gedacht.
Aber ich hatte früher überhaupt kein
Gefühl dafür, wie krass
die Leute sind.
Und jetzt, nachdem ich selbst Fahrrad fahre
und regelmäßig rennen gehe,
weiß ich,
das erstmal halbwegs einzuschätzen.
komplett vom anderen
sterben.
Was beispielsweise die Marathonläufer
machen. Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen,
wenn man selbst noch nicht gerannt ist.
Ihr könnt
es ja mal ausprobieren.
Zieht euch eine Sportuhr an
und ihr könnt es auch mit dem Handy
tracken, geht auch. Und rennt mal
fünf Kilometer. Ich wette mit
euch. Chat, Chat.
Wir müssen mal eine Umfrage machen. Moment, das muss ich
ausprobieren.
Wir machen mal eine Umfrage.
Was ihr meint.
Okay, warte mal.
Warte mal.
Sekunde, ich muss mich mal kurz muten.
Irgendwie ist mein
nicht balanced.
So, jetzt. Wir machen mal kurz eine Umfrage.
Und zwar
Parkt
ihr 5 Kilometer
Jong?
Parkt ihr 5 Kilometer
durchgängig?
Parkt ihr
5 Kilometer ohne Pause?
Dazwischen.
Ja, nein.
Oder nicht.
Packt ihr.
Glaubt ihr.
5 Kilometer
Jong ohne Pause dazwischen
zu packen.
Ja, nein.
Äh.
Wir machen nur ja, nein.
Wir machen jetzt das hier auch mal.
Und danach...
Ja, für die erste Runde,
Schäger, dreieinhalb Kilometer,
verkehrt. Du wirst sehen,
die ersten paar Wochen geht das steil bergauf.
Du packst easy demnächst fünf.
Okay, also
ungefähr ein Drittel sagt ja,
zwei Drittel sagen nein.
Okay.
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
die rennen
über 40 Kilometer
für einen Marathon.
Es ist schon
Selbst wenn man davon keine Ahnung hat
Ich kann euch sagen, es ist brutal
Heftig
Neuer Marathon Weltrekord
Hätten wir das auch
Wenn es um Leben und Tod geht, dann würde es vermutlich jeder packen.
Ja gut, bevor du abkratzt.
Gab es da nicht diesen Spruch von irgendeinem Fitness-Influencer-Typ?
Wenn man denkt, dass man nicht mehr kann, ist man erst bei 80%?
Oder irgendwie so?
Gab es da irgendwie so einen komischen Fitness-Influencer-Spruch?
so Ultramarathon Leute
ja es gibt sogar so ein Ultramarathon
Marathon Race da durch die Wüste
bei den Amis
gibt es aber hier auch
einer der besten Ultramarathon
Läufer ist glaube ich ein Norweger oder sowas
ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt
der wohnt auf einer Insel
und
eine Runde
um die Insel ist irgendwie so
10 Kilometer.
Und da läuft das
am Tag irgendwie 8 Mal oder so.
Da läuft am Tag
8 Mal 10 Kilometer.
Leute, mir tut mein Schienbein weh nach 1 Mal
10 Kilometer.
Naja.
Also ich schaff das
ohne Probleme 10 Kilometer zu rennen
mittlerweile, aber
wenn ich zu schnell bin, merke ich danach ganz schön
den Schienbein.
Jaja.
So.
Und übrigens, auch was,
ich habe es letzte Woche übertrieben.
Ich habe letzt...
Ah, es tut immer noch weh. Ich habe letzte Woche
übertrieben. Ich bin zwei Tage in Folge,
habe ich mir gedacht, komm, jetzt gib mal
ordentlich Gas, ja.
Bin ich wirklich sehr schnell geflitzt.
Einmal 8,5
Kilometer und einmal 5,5
kilometer und dann hat mir das da hat mir auf der rechten seite übelster
schienbein wehgetan und ich habe auch vorne am schienbein wenn ich da drauf
drücke so einen so einen knubbel jetzt am knochen und dr google meint das
könnte die haut vom knochen seien die sich entzündet hat das ist schlecht
deswegen fahre ich jetzt lieber ein bisschen fahrrad anstatt zu rennen
das tut das tut auch das tut auch weh wenn man drauf drückt
sieht ein bisschen aus von außen mückenstich ist aber kein stich ist so
eine harte knubbel auf knochen und wie gesagt doch der google sagt dass die
haut vom knochen die sich vielleicht verletzt hat
Lass das mit Dr. Google, ja, das ist auch besser.
Das klingt nicht so gut.
Naja, äh, es ist auf jeden Fall besser geworden.
Die Tage danach.
Und ich finde, es ist auch schon ein bisschen kleiner geworden.
Ähm, das Problem ist nur, dass ich die letzten zwei Tage wieder rennen war.
Und, äh, jetzt tut es wieder weh.
Ja, das geht auch schon wieder weg.
Und wie gesagt, ich
wollte demnächst immer wieder zum Doktor.
Also wenn das nicht besser wird.
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es was Schlimmes ist.
Es muss ja was mit dem Rennen zu tun haben.
Gerade auch, weil es weh tut, wenn man drauf drückt.
Und mehr weh tut nach dem Joggen.
Ich sollte es aber wahrscheinlich die nächsten paar Tage
nicht übertreiben.
So.
Jadgill.
7 Marathon in 7 Tagen in 7 Kontinenten.
Ey, was auch richtig krass ist,
wo wir gerade bei Weltrekorden sind.
Und, ähm,
Triathlon
120 Tage.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt? Das ist jetzt schon ein halbes Jahr her.
Okay, 2024 war das schon.
Ja.
Weltrekord.
120 Triathlon in 120 Tagen.
Der hat 120 Tage in Folge,
in Folge, ohne Pause,
120 Tage in Folge,
jeden Tag ein Ironman.
Von der Distanz her.
Das sind, was sind denn das?
3 Kilometer schwimmen,
180 Kilometer Fahrradfahren
und ein Marathon laufen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Jeden Tag.
Der ist jeden Tag
3,8 Kilometer geschwommen,
180 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren
und einen Marathon 42 Kilometer gelaufen.
Jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag. Ohne Pause.
120 Tage
am Stück.
Das ist auch
echt Next Level.
Also es gibt schon echt krasse Leute.
Ja, der musste in der Zeit nicht arbeiten.
Das hätte nicht...
Die hatten...
Ich hab da mal so eine Zusammenfassung zugeguckt.
Die hatten wirklich Probleme, weil...
Der konnte ja auch nicht zu schnell laufen, weil es zu anstrengend und zu belastend ist.
Der musste ja das möglichst schonend machen.
Das heißt, der war da ganz, ganz viele Stunden am Tag unterwegs.
Und die hatten Probleme, alles da unter die Haube zu bekommen.
Also er musste sich ja ausruhen, er musste schlafen, er musste essen, er musste massiert werden und sowas.
Und das hat alles gar nicht in 24 Stunden richtig reingepasst.
Dann war er noch irgendwie ein, zwei Mal erkältet zwischendurch.
Ja, ja, ja, richtig, richtig krass, ey.
Nun gut.
Dann gucken wir doch mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
GitHub
Trending
Weekly
in Go.
Nee, erstes Mal.
Der muss auch übelst viel futtern.
Jaja.
okay was trennt ai ai ai ai ai aber das hatten wir schon
ei ja mal sehen was trenne zu fern ist nicht gewertet wurde
habt ihr das mitbekommen bei github die hatten wohl den bug das wenn mörder
west oder wenn mörder generell wenn mörder es muss es musste wahrscheinlich
nicht mal mal zurück was über github sein also sondern es hat wahrscheinlich
auch gereicht weil ich weiß ich übrigens gar nicht hat es auch gereicht wenn man
per cli gemeldet und gepusht hat zumindest hat github probleme gehabt
mörder zu verarbeiten und hat dann ein falsches base commit genommen um darauf
zu merchen und da sind teilweise richtig
viele Sachen verschwunden und das hat nicht mehr zusammen
gepasst und
das ging ungefähr für zwei Stunden
und
wer weiß, welche Bugs
das alles produziert hat, die gar keiner gemerkt
hat.
GitHub
Status und was
viel witziger ist,
die offizielle
GitHub
github status seite die hatte hier in der zeit nichts keine keine downtime
nichts angezeigt obwohl es zwei stunden märchen nicht richtig funktioniert hat
aber die offizielle abteilung seit ist eh geschönt die hier ist viel besser
weil diese abteilung seite die guckt wenn eines der github produkte dauert
dann ist hier ein Down angezeigt und nicht wenn alles down ist und so was.
Ja, also das ist viel viel realistischer diese Einschätzung hier.
Und das hat sau viel kaputt gemacht
Also sowohl in den Repos selbst
Aber auch das Vertrauen der Leute
In GitHub
Weil wir sind ja mittlerweile schon gewöhnt
Dass GitHub mal down ist und irgendwelche Probleme hat
Und sowas
Aber dass GitHub ihre Kernfunktionen
Nationalität nämlich denn wenn ein frontend für gibt es zu sein
Verkackt
Also das hat man bis jetzt noch nicht und meiner meinung nach
Liegt es wieder daran dass microsoft irgendwas zusammen weib coded hat es gab übrigens noch eine witzige sicherheitslücke auf geht
Habt ihr das ab der github in jackson hatte das mitbekommen
News.
Script Injection.
Ne.
Header.
Ja.
Das ist auch krasser Vibe-Coding-Fail von Microsoft wieder.
So, pass mal auf.
Du konntest... Ich hoffe, die haben ein schönes Beispiel dafür drin.
Ähm...
Heise, come on.
Du konntest dort in den Push.
Du musst das Git push-o machen.
ja das kann man lesen geht push gfh research access to million of github repositories
das ist ja der wahnsinn ist ja
hier haben wir's okay
Genau, weil die machen es wohl irgendwie so, du kannst in einem Header, also wenn du den XStat Header setzt, kannst du Code injecten, indem du einfach hier Semikolon hinten dran schreibst und dann irgendein Zeug.
Also es ist quasi ein bisschen sowas wie SQL Injection, nur nicht für SQL.
Also quasi eines der oldschooligsten Sicherheitslücken, wo man sich fragt, wie kann das Microsoft passieren 2026?
Die sanitizen einfach ihren Input nicht richtig.
Die setzen hier einen Header, guck, und hier hinten kannst du beliebiges Zeug dran schreiben.
Push Option, Normal Value, Rails, Env, Staging, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Kannst da einfach Zeug hinten dran, das wird dann ausgeführt.
und ich wette mit euch das ist auch hier kommt das ist auch irgendwie durch vibe
coding schritt bei microsoft wieder entstanden
ja die schippen vielleicht five times faster aber die schippen auf 5 times
mehr schritt mit schritt
Kann man echt nur sagen hier.
So, also gucken wir mal, was weiter trendet.
KI?
Kai.
Ähm...
Dings Tool.
OS Int.
Oder wie nennt man diese Sorte Tools?
OS Int?
Irgendwas mit Int.
Nennt man den Kram doch.
OS Int.
OS Int Tool. Genau.
Git Nexus.
Zero Server Code Intelligence Engine.
Was für ein Ding?
Git Nexus is a client-side knowledge craft creator.
Was?
Chat, ich habe es gelesen.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was es ist.
Git Nexus.
The Zero Server Code Intelligence Engine.
Git Nexus is a client-side knowledge craft creator.
Was?
Okay.
Ah!
Sowas.
Gibt es manchmal Leute,
die machen so Videos auf YouTube davon,
wie sie irgendwelche GitHub-Repos entwickelt haben,
wo ich keine Ahnung habe, wer das guckt.
Das zeigt wohl irgendwelche Beziehungen zwischen
Commits und so.
Ja, okay.
Ganz ehrlich, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wann ich das benutzen würde.
Aber es hat zumindest
schon einmal
irgendwas mit KI trotzdem zu tun.
AI fully automated
shorts video engine.
Ah, mehr AI-Slop für YouTube.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste,
eines der schlimmsten AI-Slobdinger sind,
die ich auf YouTube in Shorts immer empfohlen kriege?
Das sind, vielleicht, schreibt mir mal in den Chat,
ob ihr das kennt.
Das sind Shorts, wo die sich von irgendeiner Serie
oder irgendeinem Film 30 Sekunden rauspicken
und dann ein Voice-Over haben,
was in dieser Szene passiert.
So nach dem Motto,
The man looks up looks on his watch now the man walks down the stairs
Und du kriegst 30 sekunden gezeigt und ein voice over was in dieser szene zu sehen ist
Also das ist ganz ätzend
Wollen die jetzt nicht sogar auf irgendeiner Seite einführen, dass man endlich unterscheiden...
Spotify war das.
Spotify will doch jetzt ein Tag einführen, dass man sieht, ob es KI-Musik ist oder echte Musik.
So, also
jetzt ist dieses Mal nicht wirklich viel Spannendes dabei gewesen
Guck mal mal, was bei Go so trendet
Neue F-Programmer
DS2AP Diebsieg
AI
Ich scanne schon immer unten
nach dem Cloud-Icon
Go TypeScript
Ja, okay.
Veronability Scanner.
Ich kann das Wort mittlerweile halbwegs aussprechen.
Veronability.
Vulnerability.
Letter.
Self-hosted alternative to 12 FTIO.
Was?
Was soll das sein?
Paywall Blocker.
Aha.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich schiebe das trotzdem in die gleiche Kategorie.
Sobald ein Cloud-Icon auftaucht.
Ein Cloud-Icon.
Master DNS VPN.
Advanced DNS Tunneling VPN.
Ah, für China-Chinesen VPN-Stells.
Die wurden ja geforkt zu Forgeo,
weil sie irgendwie Bedenken hatten,
dass die kommerziellen
Kram damit machen. Ich weiß
gar nicht, ob sich das jetzt so bewahrheitet
hat.
AI.
Äh, MinIO-Alternative.
Irgendein S3-Filesystem.
Olaris.
Was ist das denn?
Das kenn ich nicht.
Ein Open Source Personal Cloud.
Olaris.
Was soll das sein?
Was? Chat-GPT?
Was?
Was soll das jetzt sein?
100%
Ach, das ist, das ist
Das, das, okay
Das ist im Endeffekt einfach nur
Eine Zusammenstellung von Open Source Tools, oder?
Naja
Bisschen aus wie Google Docs.
Keine Ahnung, ob man das braucht.
Was ich viel witziger finde,
das ist lokal only, aber man kann irgendwelche
IDs erstellen.
Oder auch nicht.
Juckt mich jetzt.
Personal AI
Cloud OS. Hauptsache AI.
Kubernetes?
Was hat das mit Kubernetes?
Egal, keine Ahnung, nichts, was mich interessiert.
Ein potenziell schon
was, aber das interessiert mich nicht.
China-Chinesen-Kram?
Fabric?
AI?
Äh, weiß ich nicht.
Hatten wir aber auch, glaube ich, schon mal.
Mailing-List.
Ich meine, es gibt Leute außer dem Linux-Kernel, die noch Mailing-Listen verwenden.
Aha, gut.
So ist auch was bei Go trendet.
Gucken wir mal, was bei Rust trendet.
Blazingly Fast Z.
Gab es jetzt Version 1.0 letztens.
AI.
Ach, ne.
AI-Terminal.
Ist das nicht das Terminal, wo du ein Login brauchst,
dass du dein Terminal für verwenden kannst?
Da muss ich auch
KekW und wer das verwendet. Ein Terminal, wo ich mich
einloggen muss vorher.
Das hatten wir schon.
Das wollte ich tatsächlich mal
ausprobieren bei mir lokal. Fand ich ganz
cool, eigentlich, dass man so ein bisschen mehr
Übersicht hat über seine
Traffic, so wo das alles hingeht.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz nice. So werde ich mir, glaube ich, lokal mal
Test-Files installieren.
AI, AI, Linux-Distribution runterladen.
Data Center Scale
Distributed Interference Survey
Okay, AI
Erschback
Keiner Name
Fast Trust Based
Bundler for the Web
Webpack, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ist Webpack noch ein Ding?
Ich denke, die ganzen coolen Leute verwenden jetzt Vite.
Warum gibt es jetzt Airspac?
Und warum gibt es jetzt ein Rust Webpack, wenn doch alle...
Ist Vite auch nicht mehr in?
Ich dachte, Vite ist eigentlich das, was man jetzt verwendet.
Chatkill, ich blicke...
JavaScript-Ökosystem macht mich fertig.
Du guckst dir das mal ein halbes Jahr nicht an,
schon gibt es 30 Milliarden Sachen und alles, was du
wusstest, ist outdated.
Was zum Teufel ist Turbo Pack?
Okay, Airspark.
Airspark
für den Namen Kai, Alter.
ist a fast rust-based
Bundler-Follow-App. Okay,
Das Hauptverkaufsargument ist, dass es Rust-based ist, glaube ich.
It modernizes the Webpack-RP to enable seamless replacement of Webpack while delivering lightning-fast builds.
Okay, whatever.
Mithili.
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz...
Ich muss mal kurz auf meinem anderen Rechner was checken.
Okay, sind wir am Start.
Der Base Bundler von Vite ist auch Rust-Based.
Okay.
Turbo Pack.
WTF.
Leute, ganz ehrlich,
JavaScript mit dem Ökosystem Schritt halten kannst du nicht.
Ich bin ja schon mal froh.
Ich bin ja schon mal froh,
dass sich bei den großen Webframeworks
die letzten Jahre über doch relativ wenig ändert.
Es sind eigentlich immer noch Next.js.
ne nicht Next.js, äh Schwachsinn
React
Vue
Angular
und ein bisschen Svelte
so, es gibt zwar noch
Solid.js und hast du nicht gesehen
alles mögliche noch, aber so die
das würde ich sagen, also die großen drei
sind Vue, React
und Angular
und das schon die letzten Jahre über
kennst du das?
kann ich mich trauen das anzuklicken
Cat as a Service.
Okay, das finde ich gut.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Das ist so eine Test-AP,
wo man quasi seine
irgendwelche Exempel-Dinger
gegenprogrammieren kann.
Cat as a Service.
Rest AP to spread peace and love.
Thanks to cats.
Give me a cat.
Ja, endlich mal eine sinnvolle...
Endlich mal eine sinnvolle API, oder?
Random Cat in HTML.
Random Cat in JSON.
Aha.
Das bookmarke ich mir mal, wenn wir mal wieder irgendwelche Beispielsachen programmieren und einen APN-Punkt brauchen, nehmen wir Cat as a Service.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Privacy First AI Meeting Assistant
Äh, ne
AI
Das hatten wir schon
Stellward
Collaboration Server
Okay, es ist written in Rust, Leute
Glaube ich zumindest
Ich habe da eine Cargo-Datei gesehen
RUST!
Ähm.
But why?
Warum nicht?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher,
warum? Mail-Server-Collaboration?
Das sind doch, Leute, diese
Bilder, diese, diese, diese
Das ist doch dieses, dieses
kostenlose, dieses eine
kostenlose, ähm,
Bilderset, oder? Was total viele verwenden.
Oder sieht das einfach nur
besonders ähnlich aus?
So, dann gucken wir nochmal, was uns die
Sharp trennt als letztes.
Hey, vorher gucken wir, was den Kobold trendet.
Die wichtigsten Sachen müssen wir erstmal checken.
Okay, immer noch das Gleiche.
Was trendet denn ABAP für die SAP-Enjoyer?
Es trendet tatsächlich was.
Der Git-Client for ABAP, Leute.
ABAP-Git?
Gibt es da Examples für?
Nee.
Das will sich keiner freiwillig geben.
Ja, Documentation.
Da gibt's...
Das ist so hässlich, da gibt's doch nicht mal Examples für.
Okay, guck mal, was die Sharp trendet.
Powertoys, DNS-Server,
ShareX,
nicht zu verwechseln mit XShare.
Ja.
Porsche Helm, Unity, wartet mal...
So, Terminal Gui, Semantic Kernel, G-Helper, was auch immer. Tuning, GPU,
battery also laptops ex was excalibur auf hyper wie was was soll das sein
alles dass das video ist das das klingt ganz interessant
heckmann alternativ das kenne ich das wüsste nicht warum ich verwenden sollte aber das kenne
ich das so ein pack man gui aber ohne pack man zu sein osu für die bips wieder unter uns wir
Wir haben übrigens ein neues Emote.
Wir haben so viele
Weep Emotes. Ich habe jetzt auch ein
Anti-Weep Emote, falls ihr es noch nicht gefunden habt.
Mal gucken, wer es zuerst findet.
Hat er schon gefunden, ja.
Gab es hier schon ein Steam Controller Review?
Ne, ne, noch nicht.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe jetzt schon eine Weile nichts mehr geguckt.
Ich habe letztens, letztens, ups.
Ich hab letztens
Staffel 1 von einem fertig geguckt
Und jetzt hab ich noch nichts neues rausgesucht
Nee, irgendwie
ist Frieren Season 2 langweilig
Die erste Season war viel besser
Vielleicht tut's
Das könnte ich tatsächlich noch fertig gucken
Nee, hab ich nicht
Also ich hab
ich hab letztens die erste Staffel geguckt
von Sentence to be a Hero.
Das konnte man sich angucken.
Das war jetzt nicht so
der absolute Burner, ja.
Aber das konnte man sich schon
angucken.
Ich finde die meisten dieser, dieser
IT-Comedy-Sachen irgendwie nicht lustig.
Also ich fand weder die Office noch lustig,
noch fand ich Dings, ähm,
wie heißt das andere?
IT-Crowd oder so?
Äh, no, fand ich, fand ich nicht lustig. Ähm, weiß nicht, irgendwie ist das alles nicht so, nicht so geil.
Severance hab ich geguckt. Die zweite Staffel hat auch gesackt.
Okay, vielleicht gucke ich da nochmal rein.
So, jetzt haben wir alle Trends durch, würde ich sagen.
Chat, noch irgendeinen Wunsch, welche Trends wir uns angucken sollen, von welcher Sprache?
Also die üblichen Verdächtigen, die wir jetzt öfters benutzen, die haben wir jetzt schon.
C++, warte mal, nur um mich kurz zu quälen, okay?
Nur um mich, genau, nur um mich eine Runde zu quälen.
Kobol haben wir schon geguckt.
Kobol gab es eine Sache, die hatten wir aber schon mal.
Helium Browser.
Okay, wisst ihr
die Projekte, die C++ Projekte
Die sind schon immer so wir
dass du nicht erkennst
anhand der Beschreibung
was es sein soll, guck mal hier
Flash MLA
Efficient Multihead Latent
Attention Kernels
Was?
Was zum Teufel?
Was für ein Ding?
Efficient Multi-Head Latent Attention Kernels.
Was?
Okay.
Was ist...
Ach, geh fort.
Klingt kompliziert, ist aber im Kern eine Kombination aus drei Ideen aus der modernen KI-Forschung.
Aha.
Multi-Head Attention.
Das stammt aus dem Transformer-Modell.
Latent bedeutet verborgen.
Attention Curls, optimierte Rechenroutinen.
Optimierte Rechenmethoden, die Multi-Head-Attention nicht direkt auf allen Daten,
sondern auf komprimierten Repräsentationen berechnen und das besonders schnell.
Ich verstehe noch nicht mal die Erklärung.
Okay, was auch immer.
Firmware.
Mesh-Tastic-Firmware.
Mesh-Tastic-Henning.
Ist das nicht dieses kleine...
Dieses kleine...
Dings hier? Ja, genau.
Lama. Gut, das kennen wir.
Das haben wir auch schon mal verwendet.
Das ist absolute High-IQ-Shit.
Glaube ich dir. Gließt sich auch schon so.
Game Networking Sockets.
Das habe ich letztens tatsächlich gelesen,
dass Valve seit irgendwie 5 Jahren oder so
eine neue Version davon veröffentlicht hat.
Bamboo Studio.
3D-Printer, stell's.
Hyperland.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
kann auch sein, dass ich da falsch liege,
könnt ihr mal in den Chat schreiben,
ob ihr auch den Eindruck habt, für die ganzen Linux-Enjoyer.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
Niri läuft Hyperland
so ein bisschen den Rang ab, kann das sein?
Also zumindest, wenn man sich die YouTube-Videos
und Posts und sowas
vor anguckt würde ich sagen mir hat auf jeden fall mehr momentum aktuell als
hyperland wir müssen übrigens unser nie wie auch noch fertig einrichten habe
immer noch nicht gemacht notepad plus plus trendet ok 3d drucker stellt
nvidia game stream stellt
Ist Momentum ein Fremdwort?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das
Deutsch sagen sollte.
Mehr Beschleunigung?
Nee, äh...
Fahrtwind?
Äh...
Fahrt?
Schwung!
Schwung.
Hat mehr Schwung.
Pass, Flow, LL.
Okay.
Oh, das ist nice.
Das könnte ich auf einem Nass ausprobieren.
Da habe ich doch einen Ryzen.
Lassen wir das nicht mit Lama laufen, sondern damit.
Okay, das speichere ich mir mal.
Das probieren...
Leute, das probieren wir mal bei uns auf dem nächsten,
wenn wir wieder ein bisschen Nassstelz machen.
Probieren wir das mal auf dem Nass aus.
Gucken, ob das schneller als Ulama ist.
Habe ich hier gebuckmarkt?
Ich ziehe mir das mal kurz hin,
dass ich da dran denke.
heißt es, erwendet auch Gendersound
schwupp die Zität, ja
aber das finde ich schon ein bisschen
fremdschämen
jedes Mal, wenn ich das höre
OpenRCT2
Open Source Reimplementation of
Rollercoaster Tycoon, Moment, ist das nicht
ist Rollercoaster Tycoon
nicht zum größten Teil in Assembler
programmiert?
Oh, im Skript, das heißt
man kann es sogar im Browser ausführen
Source
Drawing
Okay, die haben es in C++
re-implemented
Ich... Wisst ihr was? Selbst ordentliches C++ sieht einfach kacke aus.
Guckt euch das doch mal an, wie diese Kacksprache aussieht, Mann.
Das ist so eine Lambda-Definition hier, das ist...
Selbst schönes C++ sieht kacke aus.
Demnächst, wie gesagt, ohne Scheiß, demnächst ist das hier irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich, ohne Scheiß, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich gültiges C++.
Wahrscheinlich geht das durch jeden C++-Parser.
Das ist wirklich hübsches C++, muss man echt mal sagen.
Da sieht man, dass man sogar in Scheißsprachen halbwegs gut lesbaren Code programmieren kann.
Und umgedreht kann man auch in an sich hübschen Sprachen unleserlichen, ekligen Code programmieren.
Naja, gut.
Kennst du schon die Reflection Syntax für C++?
Kann sein, dass ich das schon gesehen habe, aber lass mich raten, die ist hässlich as fuck, oder?
C++ Reflection Syntax.
Uiuiui.
Okay, das brauchen wir nicht.
Gibt's da irgendwie gute Examples für?
Was ist das?
Was ist das denn schon wieder?
Alter, wie viel
Rauschen möchtest du
bitteschön in Source Code drinnen haben?
Okay, Moment, ich muss das YouTube-Video
mal Probe aufmachen.
Hä?
Was hat das mit Deluxe zu tun, das Video? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Deleted World Record? What?
Das ist Trackmania oder sowas.
Operator Reflection. Okay.
Aber das sieht ja mal abfuck hässlich aus.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Template, Type Name, E.
Require Standard is E-Name.
Const, Express, Standard, String.
E-Name to String.
E-Vell, Template,
What the fuck? Wo fängt hier was an?
Und wo hört hier was auf?
Ich könnte mitraten, wo der Bug lag.
Okay.
Okay, gucken wir uns gleich an
Operator Reflections
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal kurz ein bisschen C++ flamen
Dafür muss Zeit sein
Moment, die haben nicht ernsthaft neue Zeichen
Also bald ist ja jedes Zeichen
Moment, das heißt demnächst ist
Das gültige C++-Syntax, oder was?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Und, und, und, und.
Scheiße.
What the fuck, Tim?
Ich fass es nicht.
Was zum Teufel machen die denn da?
What the fuck, Alter?
Ich trete...
Was bauen die da?
In welcher geistigen
Umnachtung befindet sich das
C++-Gremium, immer wenn die sich solche
Dinge ausdenken?
R gleich.
Oder R equals.
Hütchen, Hütchen, Int.
Und, und, und, true.
Was zum Teufel bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Es ist der...
Alter, was ist das?
Was ist das für eine Syntax, Mann?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was ist das für eine absolut
grottenschlechte Kack-Syntax?
WTF?
wiiiit, alter, wiiiit, oh Gott.
Warum
released man sowas?
Ist ja ein gutes Passwort,
ja?
D++ wirkt
einfach wie so ein
Sammelsurium aus.
Jemand hat sich mal was ausgedacht
und nix passt zusammen.
alter was ist das hier hütchen hütchen wie heißt dieses ding überhaupt richtig
heißt ja nicht hütchen da ist das zeichen zirkum flex ist es nicht
zirkum flex ist das da hallo ok
Kann Chat-GPT das vielleicht besser?
Die haben kein Leitfaden.
Was anderes kann...
Moment.
Ist Zirkumflex nicht das hier?
Ah.
Das ist das Gradzeichen.
Ja, logisch eigentlich.
Logisch.
Okay, Zirkumflex.
Das Zirkumflex meine ich, ja.
Also.
Zirkumflex, Zirkumflex, T und gleich, gleich, Zirkumflex, Zirkumflex, Int und.
Natürlich.
Obviously.
Äh
Was
TCLS
Template Auto
Kann man auch noch machen
Template Auto Struct
Ey
Kein
Ich weiß einfach nicht mehr
was ich dazu sagen soll ich glaube es wurde schon alles gesagt es ist einfach
für n arsch
koffee konnte die us in recruiter anyone feinde proposed reflection und das
distracting
Ja, das stimmt.
Und das .net C++ benutzt das.
Die C++-Programmierer
muss schon echt viel aushalten.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
Was war das nochmal?
Warum wurde das gepostet hier?
Noch generischer kann man eine
Stellenausschreibung nicht schreiben.
Als ich auf deren Seite angeschaut habe, habe ich verstanden,
wieso sie Sysadmins brauchen.
Okay, lass mal gucken.
Stepstone.
Flashbang, Alter. Moment.
Moment, Leute.
Ich kann gar nicht auf den Bildschirm gucken.
Schon besser.
Also.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Alfred, die meinen nicht C-Sharp.
Die meinen das .NET C++.
Es gibt ein C++
mit .NET-Integration von Microsoft.
Das ist das, worauf ganz viel
bei Frostbite, bei der Frostbite-Engine
zum Beispiel basiert.
Die haben ganz viele C++ .NET-Bindings
damit programmiert also das erste was mir schon mal auffällt ist wollte ich auch gerade sagen
dass die fachinformatiker für systemintegration suchen das sucht eigentlich so gut wie sonst
niemand direkt die suchen halt so was hier normalerweise schon mal nicht verkehrt dass
sie das dahin schreiben so das unternehmen komfortz steht für komfortable lösung ihrer
IT-Herausforderung. Alter, haben die das
per Chat-GPT generiert?
Wir sind ein... Okay, das ist bla bla bla bla.
Aufgaben. Konzeptionierung,
Installation, Wartung, Absicherung komplexer
IT-Systeme und Peripherie. Planung,
Implementierung und Betrieb von IT-Infrastrukturen.
Server, Storage, Netzwerk, Installation
und Umzug von PC-Servern-Systemen.
Ja, Moment. Moment mal. PC oder
Server? Da sind jetzt einfach nur zwei komplett unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe.
Die wollen quasi End-User-Client-Support und Server-Admin.
Störungsbewegung, Reparatur bzw. Austausch.
Okay, die suchen einfach jemanden, der sich vom PC und am Schreibtisch bis zum Server im Keller kümmert.
Weil ein Rechtszentrum haben die bestimmt nicht.
Administration von Servern inklusive virtualisierten Umgebungen.
Dokumentation von IT-Systemen, Umsetzung von Netzwerken, Security-Lösungen.
Verwaltung, Eingriff, Microsoft 365.
Natürlich.
natürlich. Ja, okay,
einer für alles, das ist super, du hast schon recht,
das ist super generic geschrieben.
Das ist so wirklich
sehr nichtssagend.
Xenux, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog Subscription.
Gerade mal checken,
ich habe schon mal die Hälfte vergessen.
Sonst Creator
Dashboard gucken.
LGZ Harry, danke schön für den Sub.
und ein gegifteten zap sorry habe ich nicht gesehen seit gedanken für den zap
ich hoffe du bist noch da sind rage gewittert schon und easy company
dankeschön für den zap
Profil.
Abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung.
Abgeschlossenes Studium Wirtschaftsinformatiker.
Ja, wie jetzt?
Also entweder oder.
Erfahrung als Systemadministrator zwingend erforderlich.
Erfahrung mit Microsoft-basierten Servern.
Öh.
Moment.
Ich kann dieses Emote sonst so selten verwenden.
Aber.
Geh mal bloß weg.
Der Teufel.
Sophos.
Du hast Spaß am Umgang und der Kommunikation mit Menschen.
Leute, ich bin mir relativ sicher, jemand, der das hier gerne macht, hat zu 99% wenig Spaß am Umgang und der Kommunikation mit Menschen.
Das gibt es selten in Kombination.
Zu deinen persönlichen Stärken gehören Motivation, Leistungsbereitschaft, Organisationsfähigkeit, selbstständiges Arbeiten, Wissbegierde, Zielstrebigkeit, Ergebnisorientierung, verantwortungsvolle, selbstständig, strukturierte Zeit und lösungsorientierte Arbeitsweise.
Natürlich.
Führerschein erforderlich, Zertifizierungen sind von Vorteil.
fundiertes technisches Verständnis von
IT-Infrastruktur. Idealerweise im KMU.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, was KMU...
Was ist KMU?
Kleine, mittlere Unternehmen, genau.
Deutsche
Kenntnisse, sowie Englisch-Kenntnisse
strukturieren.
Chat, ihr habt schon recht.
Direkter Kundenkontakt, auch noch?
Monk HS?
Das ist super generic geschrieben und
und
inkludiert auch gefühlt wieder einfach alles.
Also das ist keine
gute Stellenanzeige. Da würde ich mich null
angesprochen fühlen von.
Okay, was bieten sie denn?
Abwechslungsreich und
verantwortungsvolle Projekte bei kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen.
Ist das jetzt
was, was man auf der
haben hat. Das ist halt so.
Ob die Dinger abwechslungsreich sind,
wie toll die sind, muss man dann erstmal entscheiden.
Wir machen demnächst
nochmal wieder einen kompletten Stellenanzeigen-Stream.
Was ist in den Tags? Steht Linux-Server?
Bisher stand da nur Windows drin.
Direkter Kontakt zu Geschäftsführern und Entscheidern.
Ist das so ein Vorteil?
Ist das wirklich so ein Vorteil?
Wenn der Chef bei dir durchs Büro läuft
und dir auf den Sack geht?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
ob das so ein krasser vorteil ist kurze entscheidungswege und professionelles
ruhiges arbeitsumfeld
hoher gestaltung spielraum einhören gute verkehrsarbeitslosen
sozialleistungen weiterbildung mitarbeiter einen jobrat das wirkt jetzt
also irgendwie sehr 08 15 so als irgendwie möchte man möglichst
unkonkret sein so weil außer windows server also ich weiß nicht wie ist das
sehr
sehr schwammig so es könnte alles sein ja du könntest drucker patronen tauschen
oder aber ja storage netzwerk admin sachen machen also
das klingt ja das klingt schon chat gebe ich euch recht liegt ein bisschen
beknackt.
Okay, lass mal gucken, was die so treiben.
Aber anscheinend, der Laden an sich scheint ja schon mal nicht
schlecht zu sein.
Man kann jetzt bei Google mittlerweile übrigens
sehen, angeblich
2 bis 5 Bewertungen aufgrund von
Beschwerden und Diffamierung entfernt.
Wie 2 bis 5?
Weiß es Google selber nicht?
Das heißt, alle, die schlecht bewertet haben,
wurden entfernt oder?
Wir unterstellen, dass denen jetzt mal nichts böses
vielleicht waren das ja wirklich Diffamierungen
und der Laden an sich
kann ja durchaus gut sein. Das hatten wir ja schon öfters,
dass
Stellenanzeigen nicht automatisch
bedeuten, der Laden taugt nichts.
Das Problem ist nur,
Stellenanzeige
ist ein bisschen wie bei Bewerbung.
Das ist oftmals der erste Kontakt, den man mit einem Unternehmen hat.
Und wenn die schon irgendwie sass wirkt oder merkwürdig oder irgendwie nicht ansprechend wirkt, dann...
Ja, ist das wie wenn die Bewerbung sackt.
Naja Leute, so schlecht ist die Webseite doch jetzt auch nicht.
Irgendjemand hat vorhin geflamed, die Webseite wäre schlecht.
Da habe ich schon schlimmere Webseiten gesehen.
Die geht doch klar
Die schönste Webseite ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt
Aber es gibt schlimmeres
Es gibt schlimmeres
Das geht schon
Webseite war down
Okay, lass mal kurz hin
Gucken, auf was das passiert
WordPress, irgendwie dachte ich es mir fast schon
Dass es ein WordPress ist
Ah gut
Aber die Date geht doch voll klar
Das ist halt keine sonderlich gute Stellenanzeige
Das sagt aber nichts darüber aus
Ob der Laden jetzt wirklich gut oder schlecht ist
Wenn man jetzt rein nach der Stellenanzeige geht, würde ich sagen, nicht sonderlich interessant.
Was haben wir hier noch?
Ex-Hyper-V. Was war das denn jetzt?
Aquapical Hyper-V Management Tools.
Okay, das braucht man, weil das offizielle Hyper-V Management Tool so kacke ist, oder was?
China-Chinesen.
Maxi, viele Bewertungen hat dein Korean Chicken Restaurant in Frankfurt gelöscht.
Das gucken wir mal.
Chi King Frankfurt.
Das Ding ist mega geil.
Ich gehe da richtig gerne hin.
Nicht auf der Zeil, auf der Elbestraße 14.
Rezensionen?
Chat, wie bin ich denn da eben hingekommen zu dieser Seite, wo man das sieht, mit dem wie viel gelöscht wurde?
Geht das nur auf Google Maps?
was auch immer warum das in der google suche so drin ist
die löschen anscheinend nichts die tauben anscheinend habe ich doch eben
Achso hier
Aber die löschen keine Bewertung anscheinend sonst wird es ja hier stehen
Also ich kann es echt nur empfehlen
Das schmeckt richtig gut bei denen
Wer mal Frankfurt im Bahnhofsviertel ist
Und was zum Mittagessen sucht, Leute
Haut euch eine Runde
Jung-Jung-Chicken oder wie das heißt rein
Ne, WordPress Sachen hatten wir noch nicht
Aber nehmt es nicht mit Pommes, nehmt das mit Reis.
Ja gut, bei Fried Chicken ist es schwierig mit vegan.
Lua U.
Ein Mini Lua.
ok so chat noch irgendeinen wunsch zu gucken was trendet ansonsten sind wir
fertig mit github trends als 30 webseiten wish basic das ist eine gute
idee das machen wir noch mal
wichtig 6.0 konvention richtig javascript javascript javascript
können wir tatsächlich mal schnell gucken.
Wir machen
wishelbasic.net
Gibt es zweimal.
Trennt auch nichts. Okay.
Kann man eigentlich JS eintippen?
Checkt er das da? Ne. JavaScript.
Okay, was trennt bei JavaScript denn?
AI. U-Block. Sehr gut.
AI.
Äh.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Archived.
Zack.
Warum bekommt das so viel Sterne, wenn das archivet ist?
Was soll ich machen?
Animation Engine.
Boah, das...
Die haben sich jetzt aber echt die Chance entgehen lassen.
Hier irgendwas in der Richtung zu animieren.
x86 pc emulator x86 to was im jit was es nicht alles gibt all das ist das ist ein
x86 zu web assembly just in time compiler das heißt du kannst damit x86 sachen on
the fly irgendwie aus für den browser geiles zeug was nicht alles gibt alle
Babysitter
Argentic, okay
Keine Ahnung
Power Platform Skills
Also ganz ehrlich, das was
an JavaScript so trendet, hat mich
jetzt nicht so überzeugt
30 WordPress Plugins
gekauft
und Backdoor eingeschleust.
Ein Ankerber hat eine Firma übernommen,
die über 30 WordPress-Plugins
entwickelt hat. Kurz darauf schob er Nutzern
ziemlich heilig ein Backdoor.
Das ist ja mal
Next-Level-Supply-Chain-Angriff.
Die kaufen die Firma und
verbreiten dann Malware.
Damit sich das lohnt, kann die Firma
jetzt aber nicht so teuer gewesen sein, oder?
Oder es gab besonders so High-Value-Targets irgendwie.
Erstmal kurz gucken.
Einen böswilligen Akteur.
Das ist auch eine schöne Beschreibung für Angreifer, oder?
Ein böswilliger Akteur, einem böswilligen Akteur ist es gelungen, mit dem Erwerb eines WordPress-Plugin-Entwicklers, Chartcode, auf unzählige Webseiten zu schleusen und sich dadurch Backdoors einzurichten.
Davor warnt der WordPress-Hosting Anchor.
All Plugins wurden von einem indischen Team entwickelt.
Hold on, don't redeem, don't redeem.
Aufgrund der Dinge, da einer verkauft dieses Unternehmen jedoch Anfang 2025.
Okay.
Das hat es erworben.
Sechs-stelligen Geldbetrag.
Okay.
Hat erstmal ordentlich 100k oder so.
wahrscheinlich ein niedriger sechsstelliger betrag für rate ich jetzt
einmal an irgendeine sechsstelligen betrag hingelegt um sich dann um dann
irgendwie ein paar jahre später ein jahr später backdorf ob sich das gelohnt hat
ein vector eine ergänzte funktion um code von einem externen server nachzuhören
das und zur ausführung zu bringen im changeover war der war lediglich von
kompatibilität anpassung für die wordpress version die rede wordpress nutzer sollten
handeln die genannten beckdorf allerdings nicht sofort aktiv erst anfang april begann die plugins
von verdächtigen code nachzuladen da die plugins der entwicklerfirma zusammen auf mehr als 400.000
aktive ach so ich habe gedacht es gibt das habe ich ich kann knupp alter ich habe gedacht es gibt
ich habe das falsch gelesen ich habe gedacht 30 wordpress installationen benutzen das nein es
sind 30 plugin bei über 400.000 installation okay dann sieht die sache schon mal ganz anders aus
dann sieht das schon mal ganz anders aus
der entwickler von wordpress soll diese schon unschädlich gemacht
Das ist ja auch mal was, hä?
Max, hast du bei dir
eigentlich schon Glasfaser? Ne,
hab ich nicht. Leider. Ich bin sofort dabei.
Wenn die hier sagen, Max,
wir bauen aus,
Willst du es bei dir in den Keller gelegt haben?
Ich bohre denen das Loch sogar selbst, wenn die wollen.
Na gut, das kann ich nicht, weil dann muss ich die Straße aufmachen vorher.
Aber ich bin sofort dabei, sobald die das hier legen.
Wem gehört denn WordPress eigentlich?
Okay.
Anscheinend
keinem Großen.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich,
dass LinkedIn Microsoft gehört?
Ich vergesse, ich denke da immer nicht dran.
Ich habe auch kein LinkedIn Account.
Kein Bock auf den Scheiß.
So, was haben wir denn hier heute empfohlen bekommen?
Okay, irgendjemand meinte, das hier ist spannend und wir können mitraten, wo das Problem liegt.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Ich bin ja immer skeptisch bei random Videos, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, um was es geht.
Investigating the mystery behind my deleted world record.
Have you ever wondered what it feels like to make history?
Only to be erased from it.
Muss ich ein bisschen lauter machen?
Ah, ich hab's im falschen Browser auf, hier hab ich keine Lautstärkeregelung.
33 Minuten?
Ne, das ist zu lang. Das kann ich mir nicht angucken jetzt.
Wenn ich ein Video angucke, wo es um Linux und Technik geht
und es ist 33 Minuten lang,
da bin ich ja um 12 Uhr nicht fertig.
Na, gucken wir mal.
Wir gucken mal, ob das spannend ist.
Okay, es ist irgendein Trackmania-Ding.
Äh, Tati, du meinst ProtonDB?
ProtonDB, meinst du?
Eines der Rekorde, die ich im letzten Jahr gedreht habe, wird immer wieder von Nadio gelöscht für...
Dann hast du so andere Sachen wie Rainbow Six.
Das geht nicht, weil Anti-Cheat.
Das ist eine Franzose? Hört sich ein bisschen so an, oder?
Okay.
Es gibt die initialen Abwärtsgänge und sparen ca. 0,3 Sekunden.
Mit ihnen hat er eine Zeit von 54,8 Millionen...
kann man sie immer ganz gut angucken.
Obwohl ich selbst absolut kein Interesse daran habe Trackmania zu spielen.
Ich spule da kurz ein bisschen vor.
reported something really weird.
Well, I don't know man.
You've been seeming sus lately.
Three days after I did it,
my EO2 run had been
removed from the game.
When I saw it, I was honestly in shock.
I opened the game to double check
and yeah, it was actually gone.
I got pretty frustrated and confused,
especially because the next day,
Stunt Mod was releasing in TM2020, meaning
it was really unlikely that Nadio would spend time
Also habe ich die Probleme überall aufgelistet, mit dem Live-Rekord meiner Runde, hoffentlich
wird jemand es ernst nehmen.
Was die meisten verwirrt war die komplette Verleihung der Erklärung.
Natürlich, die Runden wurden vorher gelöscht, aber meistens ist es nur so, wenn der Spieler
die Physik deutlich vermischt oder die Spielweise irgendwie verändert.
Also zu verstehen, warum die ganze Situation so überraschend war.
Wir müssen über das über was wir eigentlich wissen,
über Trackmania 2s Antizipationen reden.
Könnte er dann das Recht das löschen?
Ich werde später erklären, wie eine Validation in Detail funktioniert, aber...
Na, benutzen die KI dafür und KI hat das dann aus Versehen gelöscht, oder wie?
Für jetzt, die einfache Version ist dies.
Die Spiele simulieren den Replay und beobachten,
ob die Zeit, die du gedroht hast, die Zeit, die die Simulation produziert, vergleichbar ist.
Wenn jemand die Physik, zum Beispiel mit einem Boost-Hack,
die Simulation nicht vergleichbar ist und die Spiele den Rund und den Replay entfernen.
Das gleiche passiert, wenn du während deiner Runde pausierst,
die Inputs in den Replay-File,
die automatisch die Validation
verfehlen. Das ist es.
Wo wir übrigens wieder dabei sind,
das geht jetzt zwar
nicht drum, aber daran sieht man,
Server-Side
ist bei Online-Games einfach
beste.
Da kannst du halt gleich viel weniger
cheaten, viel weniger bescheißen.
Deswegen gibt es bei MMOs auch so wenig
Cheats. Mario, danke schön
für den Sub.
Das war's für heute.
Ich habe keine Programmien gebraucht, die das Spiel verändert haben und es gibt keine
schrecklichen Inputs.
Zweitens, mein Rennen wurde drei Tage nachdem ich es gesagt habe gelöscht.
Das ist wirklich seltsam.
Sie sehen, die Spiele können...
Ja normalerweise müsste es ja bei der ersten Nacht schon gelöscht werden, wenn das dieses
automatische Cheat Detection ist.
...die Liederbord jeden Tag in Europa um 8 Uhr.
Vor vier Jahren wurden, wie die, die die Physik tweaken, für Beispiel, die offensichtlich
am nächsten Tag, aber nicht dieses Mal.
Und letztlich habe ich eine Validierung auf meinem gespeicherten Replay mit der Ingame Option gehalten
und es hat meinen Rundgang als komplett validiert.
Ich habe nicht gefehlt, aber das Spiel hat es trotzdem entfernt.
Dieses System hat in den letzten Dekaden nie einen falschen Positiven produziert,
zumindest nicht, dass wir davon wissen.
Um die Dinge noch weh zu machen, habe ich versucht, den Replay an die Server zu resubmittieren,
Multiple times, exploiting various in-game bugs to force it through.
But nothing worked.
So, actually, what really happened to my war record?
Thanks to the solid truth...
I didn't shit.
...with Discord and especially the work of Big Bang and Mystics,
we finally have the answer.
The first thing Big Bang looked into was the validation process.
The fact that Myron kept getting deleted
meant the game's anti-cheat was flagging it as invalid,
even though the in-game validation said otherwise.
Das heißt aber auch,
es gibt keinerlei RNG
in diesem Game, oder?
Oder ein RNG, na doch, doch, doch, doch.
Oder der Seed muss halt
stimmen.
Dass die Simulation und das Replay
den gleichen Seed für den RNG verwendet.
Dann würde es auch funktionieren.
Max, hast du die Erinnerung von GitHub Copilot mitbekommen?
Ist jetzt Monkarib für Unternehmen?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Wieso? Was ist da schon wieder?
Wir hatten es heute schon öfters von GitHub, aber das hatten wir noch nicht.
map der das ist das neue video von morpheus geguckt nee
gucken wir mal kurz was hat er denn
aber was spannendes
brandneue
einer stunde ich habe mein internet zurückerobert
Okay, können wir nachher vielleicht noch gucken.
Der Internet hat eine...
GitHub Copilot just died.
Ist das so?
Jetzt gucken wir erstmal das Trackmania-Video fertig.
Ich kann ja nicht immer alles anfangen und dann nie fertig gucken.
check so big bang hat an idea test the run from that use perspective normally
that we mean that somehow we could access their servers directly it has
written a point to get a need to know that you had already given the community
the tools to host their dedicated service complete with their own
validation system it's not something server host usually use but for us it
was perfect it is a direct vision into how nadia validates runs and even better
they provided both windows and linux versions so we could test the replay on
both operating systems just like that you would there are two reasons we're confident that this
is the same validation system that you use in game first the games physics are identical between solo
and multiplayer so sag mal ist kann man aber da nicht trotzdem übelst schieten wenn
wenn man dann ein replay einschicken kann und die simulieren das replay auf server seite und
wenn das matcht, dann passt es.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Aber, ähm, wenn ich jetzt,
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise, ähm,
Tastatur-Inputs und so simuliere,
sodass das quasi perfekt fährt auf der Strecke,
dann kriege ich ja ein gültiges, ein gültiges Replay-File.
Und kann das Submiten, ohne dass ich, ohne, ohne dass ich selbst gefahren bin.
Okay, oh, Alter.
und der Source Code war genau zwischen den drei.
Big Bang hat mein Replay durch die Windows-Validation gespielt.
Resultat? Valid.
Das sollte bedeuten, dass Nadio's Anti-Cheat es auch akzeptieren wird.
Aber um es einfach zu beobachten, hat er auch die Linux-Version gecheckt.
Jedoch kam das Ergebnis zurück.
Invalid.
Super!
Also der Run ist im Spiel valid.
Es ist valid mit Nadios eigener Windows-Validation.
Aber auf Linux?
Es ist valid?
Im Zweifelsfall schieb ich's auf Wayland.
Ich weiß, Wayland hat absolut nichts damit zu tun,
aber ich schieb's trotzdem mal drauf.
Sollte an der Stelle absolut null Unterschied machen.
Du kannst es sogar headless auf dem Server laufen lassen.
Hat null mit Wayland zu tun,
aber ich musste mal ein Wayland-Flame heute noch einbauen.
Was könnte das denn sein?
Irgendwelche GLEP-C-Geschichten,
sich ein bisschen irgendwelche standard c library funktion die sich ein bisschen
anders verhalten zwischen windows und linux
ich habe keine ahnung
dieses Alternativ-Operationssystem zu Windows und MacOS, aber nie vollständig verstanden,
was es eigentlich ist.
Nun, Linux, wie die anderen beiden, ist verwendet, um deinen Computer zu fahren.
Die Hauptunterschiede sind, dass es open source ist.
ist raus. Please allow me to interject for a moment. Oder wie manche Leute es nennen,
GNU plus Linux.
Nadio nutzt Linux um ihre Server zu managen.
Der Grund dafür ist, dass Linux perfekt für sie ist.
Das sind die alten Visio-Bildchen hier, guckt mal.
Wir werden sehen, dass es eigentlich Linux nutzt.
Vielleicht ist die Map, die wir spielen, und die, die Nadio auf ihren Servern hat,
immer so ein bisschen anders.
Vielleicht ist mein Rundweg über einen Block, der nicht genau der gleiche war zwischen den beiden Versionen.
Mit keinem Lied in der Schale, war das Ende der Investition an diesem Punkt.
Ein Monat nach der ersten Investition hatte ich noch so viele Fragen.
Ich habe also mein Freund Mip12 geholfen.
Er hat mir einige Tricks gezeigt, um meinen Run-Breen zu den Leaderboards zu stellen.
Vielleicht war es nur ein Fehler, und mein Rode wäre einfach okay, wenn wir ihn einfach zurück zu den Servern senden.
Das erste, was wir versucht haben, war eine Basis für Autosave-Manipulationen.
Es geht so weiter.
Sie nehmen das Autosave-File und bewegen es aus dem Folder, in dem es war, bevor es verlost wurde.
Dann entdeckst du das Stadium.score-File, das in der Karte im Programmdata-Folder verwendet wird.
Danach öffnest du das Spiel und schließt es sofort.
Das fordert das Spiel, ein neues Score-File zu erstellen, das dann deine Autosaves erzeugt,
außer natürlich, dass die verlagerte Runde missbraucht wird.
Nun setzt du das Autosave zurück in seine originale Folie und voila!
Wenn du das Spiel wieder öffnest, sieht das Score-File ein neues Autosave, das es noch nie gesehen hat.
Da es bemerkt, dass du keine persönliche Besten auf dieser Karte hast,
sendet es automatisch die Autosaves an Nadio's Server.
Smart, oder?
Ja, es hat gut funktioniert.
Für 16 Stunden.
Also war es kein Fluch.
Vielleicht wurde die Replay selbst geäußert, also testen wir die Runde.
Dieses Mal wurde das Replay-File und alles darin neu generiert.
Gleiches.
Verlässt am nächsten Tag.
An diesem Punkt war die Situation klar.
Etwas war grundlegend falsch.
An diesem Punkt war es so seltsam, dass die Community sich zusammengestellt hat, um zu versuchen,
was hier überhaupt passiert ist.
Auch Riolu hat ihm Hilfe gegeben.
Vielen Dank, Riolu.
Ich liebe dich, aber das ist sehr falsch.
An dieser Zeit fragte MDF, was passieren würde,
wenn wir andere Replays von der Map probieren.
Speziell Phipps Run.
Und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt, war er valid.
Meine Runden wurden wieder als falsche Simulation getestet.
Das bedeutet, dass die Simulation auf Linux
nicht mal bis zum Schluss erreicht ist.
Das bedeutet, dass die Inputs, wenn gedreht, gut sind,
aber wenn es irgendwie simuliert wird, kann es nicht einmal die Map beenden.
In der Zwischenzeit versuchen wir gemeinsam mit Mieb, zu finden, an welchem Punkt
viel viel mehr probleme schon gegeben
vielleicht habe eine idee compiler optimierung
compiler optimierung
die unter linux andere sachen optimieren wir unter windows
irgendwelche gcc geschichten unter windows unter windows
kompilieren die mit dem Visual Studio Compiler
und unser Linux kompilieren die mit GCC und passiert vielleicht ganz subtil irgendwas anderes
oder irgendwelche Compileroptimierung die Sachen bei dem einen löschen bei dem anderen
nicht irgendwie sowas in der Richtung vielleicht
point and manually drive the rest of the map. This will give us a baseline to see if the inputs we
injected with TAS are still valid or not. If the run is still valid, we can conclude that the
desync occurs before the cutoff of the injected inputs. We launch the TAS tool created by Schwitz.
Dieses Software wird uns ermöglichen, Inputs zu laden und sie auf einer exakten Replik auf der Strecke zu spielen,
damit sie sich nicht mit anderen aktuellen Lido-Boards verbinden.
Für die visuelle Beleidigung, hier ist, wie die Inputs aufgespielt werden.
Hier ist, wann der Input benutzt wird.
Man kann eine Aktion jeden 0,01 Sekunden oder 100 Mal pro Sekunde machen.
Dann kann man die Aktion sehen, ob man drückt, los oder dreht,
abhängig davon, welchen Input man auswählen möchte.
Und dann die Unterkante selbst oder die Größe der Dreher, die man will.
Die Dreher sind aufgespielt.
die in diesem Replay-File drin gespeichert sind.
Ja, das ist ein Signed-Int.
Äh, kein Signed-Int,
ein Int, ein Int, ein Signed-Int 16, oder?
Chat, bin ich jetzt
ein Signed-Int 16, oder?
MonkHS.
Senior Linux Engineer, by the way.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Int 16.
Nee.
Fuck.
Leute.
Falsch.
Failed.
Kein Int 16.
Gibt es so was wie
Wir brauchen einen N24, weil ein N32 ist ja deutlich mehr.
Ist ein N24?
Aber das müsste auch mehr sein.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich einen N17.
Aber einen N17 gibt es doch nicht.
Okay.
Hä?
Ja, ich würde sagen, dass es nicht so einfach ist.
Ich würde auch sagen, die benutzen ein unsigned Int 16 und speichern sich das Vorzeichen irgendwo anders.
Also quasi ein Bool und ein Int 16.
5er Streak, bock.
Ich habe jetzt 1.83 Sekunden Inputs.
Der Run ist perfekt gut in der Validation.
Das heißt, dass, egal wie ich gespielt habe, nach 1.5 Sekunden,
mein Run durchdelt wurde durch ein Fehler, um meinen Run auf Linux zu validieren.
Und da das replikabel ist, heißt das, dass wenn du diesen gleichen Strang Inputs auf EO2 auswählen,
dein Run auch auf Linux invalidiert wird.
Well, no matter what you do after it.
Now what exactly?
We have a replay that is valid on Windows
but not on Linux.
It doesn't bug because of an element inside the file itself
but because of the exact and replicable
string of inputs.
What else can we try really?
You know, the conversation continued a bit
Aber wir haben einfach nur Ideen verloren.
Wie kannst du so etwas erklären?
Hier wieder, die Investition hat lange gedauert.
Für die nächsten Monate hat EO2 die Hauptpersonen investiert.
Das kann nur durch einen Unfall passieren.
Etwas muss im Spiel sein, aber was?
Ich habe sogar versucht, die Map auf dem Stream zu replayen, aber ohne Anwendung.
Fast ein Jahr später, im August 2025, war Big Bang an einem persönlichen Projekt gearbeitet.
Eine App für die Mania Planet Manager, die auf Alpine gebaut wurde, eine kleine Linux-Vertragung.
Während des Experimenten mit der Replay-Validation...
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wenn es bei Alpine jetzt geht, ist es G-Lip C vs. Musel, was Probleme macht?
Er erinnert sich an das unbefugte Geheimnis der vorherigen Befugnis.
Er hat sich entschieden, den Replay wieder zu testen, ohne etwas Neues zu erwarten.
Aber dieses Mal war das Ergebnis anders.
Der Replay war validiert.
Ich lag gar nicht weit weg.
Leute, mein erster Guess war gar nicht so schlecht, oder?
Moment.
Perfekt in Alpine.
Er war immer noch in...
Mein Alpine plus G lebt C?
Ach so.
Ich dachte...
Valid on Ubuntu, but valid on Alpine at least.
He tested another distribution, Debian.
Again, wrong simulation.
Big Bang shared his findings with the rest of us and the conclusion shifted dramatically.
The issue wasn't with Nadio's server's build or validation at all.
Instead, the problem seemed to come from the Linux libraries responsible for the calculations during the validation.
Here's why.
Aber ich finde es interessant, dass die Alpine Linux plus GLibc machen und da geht's und Debian mit GLibc funktioniert nicht.
Ich hätte gedacht, der Unterschied wäre dann vielleicht zwischen der Standard-Style.
Ist das irgendeine GLIB-C-Version?
System, etwas weit über einem einfachen Patch.
Also war es klar an diesem Punkt.
Mein Run ist verdammt und wird wahrscheinlich nie, nie wieder zurück auf die Lead Awards.
Aber die Frage bleibt immer noch.
Welche Version von Linux benutzt Nadeo tatsächlich?
Mit so viel Unabhängigkeit zwischen Distributions, identifizieren das genau, was TrackNerd für
Validation nutzt, ist wirklich wichtig.
Ein Ansatz ist es, einen Anruf an Nadeos Server zu senden und die Antwort zu analysieren.
Leider zeigen die Serverheader nicht, welche Distribution genutzt wird.
Wir können aber noch einen anderen Trackmania Titel aufschauen.
Während des Trackmania Turbo Lido Board Projekts,
hat Future Cat einen wichtigen Detail entdeckt.
Eine Wechselstunde zu Trackmania Turbos Website
hat einen Header mit
X Powered by PHP 5591 Ubuntu 420 eröffnet.
Das suggeriert,
Ubuntu 420
dass Nadeo Ubuntu 420 verwenden könnte,
wahrscheinlich Version 14, die 2014 veröffentlicht wurde.
Das ist nur ein beruflicher Witz, basierend auf der unbekannten Information, die wir haben.
Nadio könnte eine völlig andere Distribution für ihre Server haben,
aber Ubuntu 14 bleibt hier der wahrscheinlichste Szenario.
Das ist Trackmania Turbo, über den wir reden.
Das Spiel wurde ein Jahr vor dem Nadeo-Rearbeiten der ganzen Trackmania 2-Environmente ausgewählt.
2017 haben sie die Physik des Spiels verändert,
wenn sie von Mania Planet Version 3 nach Version 4 gewechselt haben,
also ein fast ganz neues Spiel.
Es würde auch Sinn machen, wenn sie das gleiche Setup als Trackmeat Turbo für Trackmeat 2 nutzen,
da sie die beiden Spiele fast gleichzeitig bauen.
Während all dessen wurde MDF interessiert und wollte selbst die Run veranstalten.
Er hat sie auf der Distribution, die Fedora verwendet hat, probiert und die Run veranstalten.
Dann hat er es auf der Distribution, die man veranstalten muss, veranstalten,
die schon eine Run-Simulation-Resultate gezeigt hatte.
Er hat weitergegeben und hat die Run-Situation von Ubuntu probiert.
ist valid true.
Er hat gedouble checked und das selbe Ergebnis erscheint.
Um es klar zu machen, war mein Run sowohl valid als auch invalid,
abhängig davon, wer es getestet hat.
Big Bang hat dann über jedes mögliche Setup von Ubuntu versucht.
Linux Docker, Windows Docker, Ubuntu WSL, RAW Ubuntu und es hat immer gefehlt.
Es ist keine Bedrohung, all diese Details zu erklären,
aber der Punkt ist, dass er alles versucht hat, was er konnte,
Ubuntu hat einfach nicht mehr den Rundentakt verabschiedet.
Das ist interessant.
Vielleicht hat das mit der Version der Distribution zu tun.
MDF hat auf der neuesten Version, Ubuntu 25.04, getestet,
während Big Bangs Setup auf Ubuntu 22.10 läuft.
Könnte es sein, dass das Verabschiedungsproblem irgendwo zwischen diesen Versionen festgelegt wurde?
Nach ein bisschen mehr Testen kam es heraus, dass die Version, die MDF 25.04 benutzt hat,
glücklicherweise der erste war, wo die Verabschiedung auf Ubuntu richtig funktioniert hat.
Das war ein Glückesbrief, weil wir jetzt analysieren können, welche großen Veränderungen in dieser Version vorgelegt wurden.
Ubuntu 25.04 wurde nur vier Monate hervorragend veröffentlicht.
14 hat bei dem anderen funktioniert weil wenn die gleiche ubuntu version bei dem einfunktion
bei dem anderen nicht liegt vielleicht daran dass die unterschiedliche cpu oder sowas haben
wenn sie durch die change log der wassignifikant die von spät in der 2 u2 versions was die
spezifische funktionskunde gmc ja aber chat wenn es wenn es das wirklich ist irgendwas bei
da müsst ihr zugeben ich habe mit meinem ersten guest gar nicht schlecht gelegen weil eines der
ersten sachen die ich gesagt habe irgendeinen unterschied geliebte zwischen windows und linux
Das hätte ich aber...
Das war das erste, was ich mir gedacht habe, aber auf der anderen Seite, dann müsste es...
Also wenn das...
Dann muss das irgendwie ein ganz, ganz seltener Fehler sein, weil ansonsten würde es ja noch viel mehr Probleme machen.
Das wird ja gefühlt überall verwendet.
Library of Functions for the Programming Language C, made by the GNU organization.
The new version of the library, quote, optimized and correctly rounded 23 functions related to logarithms, trigonometry and exponentials.
Pretty much everything that you'd expect being crucial for a physics engine.
From there, we have a list of suspects.
One or several of these updated functions had to be responsible for breaking the simulation of my world record.
Sie schauen sich diese Liste an, es ist wirklich unklar, welche verantwortlich war.
Also hat Mysticsaur entschieden, welche dieser Funktionen tatsächlich während der Validierung verwendet wurden.
Um das zu tun, hat er das Validationsprogramm durch einen Debugger gehalten.
Ein Debugger ist ein Programm, das ein anderes Programm in einem kontrollierten Weg verwendet.
Was für uns interessant ist, ist, dass man Breaking Points setzen kann, die, wenn getriggert werden,
wenn und warum etwas passiert.
Mysticsaur setzt dann einen Trigger auf jede Funktion, die durch die Update der Bibliothek geändert wurde, und dann schafft er den Debugger.
Wie es sich herausstellt, benutzt die Validation nur die 10f, 8nf und 8n2f Funktionen aus allen 23.
Wir können alle ungenutztes Funktionen auswählen, die wir wissen, dass die Fehler nicht von ihnen entstehen können.
Für die Mathem-Drohier sind die drei Funktionen entsprechend verantwortlich für die Ergänzung der Tangent, Arch-Tangent und Arch-Tangent von einer Ratio von zwei Nummern.
Um zu kontrollieren, welche der letzten 3 Funktionen die Fehler hervorbringt,
Mysticsaur hatte die Idee, die Rückwarnung der Funktion zu beobachten und die Unterschiede zwischen den beiden Funktionen zu beobachten.
Siehst du, eine Funktion, sei es die tangent Funktion, wird, wenn die Programm-Exekution erledigt wird,
erledigt und eine gekalkulierte Wertung zurückgegeben.
Wenn wir also die Rückwarnung einer Funktion auf der Version beobachten, die die Validierung brechen,
dann können wir sie mit der Rückwarnung der Updated Funktion an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt vergleichen und sehen,
Wenn die Rückmeldung gleich ist, kann diese spezifische Anzeige der Funktion nicht die Grundlage der Fehler sein,
denn egal, was die Version ist, wird das Ergebnis der Funktion gleich sein.
Was wir mit diesem Methoden sehen wollen, ist, dass an jedem Punkt eine der drei Funktionen eine
Zahl zurückgibt, die sogar etwas anders ist als die neu erneut, diese Unterschiede verbreiten werden.
Die gealterte Zahl wird an andere Funktionen überwiesen, die dann ihre eigenen etwas andersen Ergebnisse erzeugen,
bis zu dem Punkt, wo die Wertungen zwischen der alten und der neuen Version so groß werden,
Das wird die Unwahrheit des Falsches triggeren.
Um diese Methode zu nutzen, sind wir zurückgekehrt zum Debugger.
Diese Zeit, jedes Anruf zu einer der drei verleugneten Funktionen,
wird das Rückwarnungswert eines Files, ein nach dem anderen, aufgeloggt.
Nach dem Wiederholen des Prozesses,
Aber nicht schlecht, dass sie das rausgekriegt haben.
Da war schon ein bisschen Big Brain Time angesagt.
mit der verbesserten Funktion, hatten wir zwei File.
Jede Linie in einem File,
die zu dem gleichen Funktionsanruf in der...
Also ich hätte an der Stelle aufgehört, wo ich rausgekriegt hätte,
dass es der Unterschied ist zwischen GLIB C24 und 241.
Hätte ich gesagt, okay, liegt eindeutig an irgendwelchen Änderungen da drin,
aber weiter geguckt mit dem Debugger oder hätte ich dann nicht mehr.
In Hexadezimal kann man auch Kaffee schreiben und das ist gültig.
von jeder Funktion. Jetzt, dass wir die File haben, schauen wir uns die Daten an.
Die meisten der geschriebenen Werte verglichen sich zwischen Versionen, was ein guter Punkt ist,
aber einige verschwinden nur ein bisschen. Hier beobachtet. Nehmen wir die erste Distributie.
Die letzte Digit fliegt von 3a zu 3b. Das ist ein kleiner Veränderung. In flotternden Punkt-Termin
Die Unterschiede hier sind nur 0.00000006.
Um zu beurteilen, ob dieser Art von Bitflip normal ist, haben wir den Prozess mit einem Run gewechselt,
der keine Veränderung triggert, speziell Phipps Run. Hier sind die zwei File, die die
Rückwarn-Werte für seinen Replay zeigen. An erster Sicht ist ein einziger Bit-Change in der
exakt gleichen Zahl unvergleichbar. Um dies zu visualisieren, können wir die Unterschiede plotieren.
Wenn die Zahlen zwischen den beiden Filen miteinander verglichen sind, können sie sich auf dem Graph ausstellen,
aber wenn ein Bitflip passiert, sehen wir einen kleinen Bump.
Dies lässt uns einfach bemerken, wo und wie oft diese kleinen Unterschiede passieren.
Dies ist der Graph für Phipps-Front.
Wie erwartet, sind kleine Unterschiede von einem hier und da, ganz normales Verhalten.
Aber was passiert, wenn wir den Graph für meinen geladenen Replay plotten?
Ja, das ist dann einmal über einem gewissen Wert gewesen.
Und nachdem es ja alles aufeinander aufbaut, ist dann vorbei.
Das Verhalten verändert sich komplett. Die Unterschiede explodieren ständig.
Der Validations-Algorithmus sieht den Rundweg als zu weit entfernt vom Replay-File und stoppt ihn,
beziehungsweise verhindern, dass mein Rundweg invalid ist.
Der Moment, an dem die Kaskade beginnt, ist offensichtlich.
Das ist ungefähr dort, wo alles zerfallen lässt.
Nur durch das Zuschauen der Rundwerte ist es unmöglich,
zu beurteilen, welcher Bitflip das Problem verursacht.
Um die Veränderung zu isolieren, soll Mysticsor den Methoden vorlegen,
eine gefliebte Wertung neben dem Start der Kaskade zu identifizieren,
dann das Programm wieder in den Debugger zu runtern. Diesmal wird der Debugger auf das spezifische Ergebnis warten.
Wenn er gefunden ist, wird er die gefliepte Zahl mit der korrekten aus dem neu erhobenen File verändern,
wie ein Szenario, in dem der Fliegende nie geschehen ist. Wenn die Kaskade immer noch stattfindet,
war der Testfliegende nicht die Grundlage für den Fehler der Validierung.
Die haben es sich schon eine hardcore Mühe gegeben, hier das rauszufinden.
Vanished? That flip could be framed as the prime cause.
After over a year of investigation conducted by half a dozen community members...
Wie die einfach damit mehrere Leute über ein Jahr dran rum...
Ja gut, aber ich kann es schon irgendwie verstehen.
Das ist sowas, also kommt immer auf die Leute an, ja.
Aber wenn du dich erstmal reingebissen hast in sowas, du willst es dann auch lösen.
Sonst drehst du durch.
At precisely 0.85 seconds into the run, the validation process calls the A102F function.
This call returns the floating value 1.5889542,
corresponding to the hexadecimal 3FCB62DA, ending with an A, where it should end with a B.
The difference is just 0.0000001.
Ein einziger Zehntelmillionstel von einem Unit.
Und zwar trotz seiner miniskulen Größe.
Diese kleine Unabhängigkeit war genug, um die gesamte Validierung zu verursachen.
In Wahrheit war die Errung so subtil, dass, obwohl der Flip so früh passiert ist,
es fast acht Sekunden dauerte, bis die Validierung endlich zerstört wurde.
Es ist eine Erleichterung, endlich zu verstehen, was falsch ist,
besonders nachdem so viele Leute sich mehrere Stunden auf dieses Geheimnis gebeten haben.
Es war ein echter Puzzle, der alle zusammengebrochen ist.
Der Timestamp bestätigt sogar unsere früheren Finde mit Mieb.
Wir haben erwartet, dass die Fehler zwischen 0,83 und 1,50 Sekunden hervorgehoben sind.
Und jetzt wissen wir, dass es tatsächlich bei 0,85 Sekunden auf dem Punkt war.
Wir wissen, dass die Unterschiede in den Werten zwischen den Funktionsversionen...
Aber ist diese Unterschiede tatsächlich in der Replay sichtbar?
Man kann nicht das, was in der Validation passiert, in eine sichtbare Replay übersetzen.
Aber es gibt einen Weg, um zu beenden.
Wenn du eine Runde validierst, ist die Hintergrundsicht blank, nichts wird erzeugt.
Aber erinnere dich daran, was die Validation tatsächlich macht.
Sie vergleicht die Position der simulierten Fahrzeuge mit der Position, die in dem Ghostfile gespeichert wurde.
Mysticsaur hat ein Tool gebaut, das die Vergleiche visualisiert,
um zu zeigen, wo die Validation denkt, dass die Fahrzeuge sein sollten.
Das zeigt uns die simulierte Position von Seite zu Seite mit dem eigentlichen Replay,
Frame zu Frame, bis zum Moment, wo die Validation verfehlt wird.
Es ist subtil, aber man kann es sehen.
Auf der linken Seite die simulierte Position und auf der rechten Seite das eigentliche
Replay im genau gleichen Frame, wo alles vorbeigeht.
Die Differenz ist klein, aber sie ist da.
Man kann es sehen, wenn ich zoome.
Wie schon erwähnt, entsteht das Missvergleich der Wertung bei 0,85 Sekunden und hier, die letzten simulierten Frames, passieren bei 8,21 Sekunden in der Run.
Für eine Historie...
Das war's für heute.
was Gaming angeht, Franzosen auch geflamed,
so nach dem Motto, gerade in Online-Games,
so reden immer Französisch und nicht Englisch
und sowas, aber ich hab da mittlerweile
meine Meinung geändert, zumindest über ein paar.
Ich hab jetzt jahrelang mit
Franzosen MMOs gespielt,
oder MMO gespielt,
wobei das ja echt eine wilde Mischung war.
Wir hatten einen Schweizer Franzose,
einen Französischen Franzose,
einen Italiener,
einen Däner,
mich,
Noch ein Italiener?
Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Also es war wirklich wild, wild gemischt.
Und mit den Franzosen war wirklich super zu spielen, ja.
Kompletter Spaghetti-Coater-Spiel.
Woher weiß man das?
Haben die mal irgendwo was veröffentlicht oder wurde mal irgendwo was geleakt oder so?
Es könnte aber auch ein weiterer Fall sein, aber es ist wirklich unklar, ob das gleiche Problem geschehen wäre.
Am 6. Juni 2018 setzte Spieler Quacker seinen ersten Weltrekord auf der Map D14 Lagoon,
sogar live im Stream. Aber im November des letzten Jahres ging er, um seinen Rekord seinen Zuschauer zu zeigen,
und er war weg. Sein Weltrekord war weg. In Unwahrheit spielte er wieder den Track, um zu sehen, ob er
Es ist ja, er hat Nadio für Antworten kontaktiert, aber er hat nie eine Antwort erhalten, wie ich.
Quaker hat den Wall Record endlich zurückgeleitet, aber ohne Zugang zu seiner originalen Replay können wir nicht beurteilen, ob er die gleiche Fähigkeit wie ich verursacht hat.
Ohne weiteres Beweis, steht mein Rennen als der einzige Beurteilungskreis,
der aufgrund eines Faktionswertes von Windows und Linux ausgelöst wurde.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dies passiert, scheint astronomisch niedrig zu sein.
Schauen wir uns den fünften Rund und meine ersten 0,85 Sekunden an,
sind etwa 20% aller Rückwarnungswerte zwischen Windows und Linux falsch.
Mit jedem Bitflip, der eine Runde invalidieren kann,
wie viele tatsächlich einen brechen.
Der mittlere Rund dauert etwa 59 Sekunden und enthält ungefähr 2500 Bitflips.
Über alle vier Umgebungen mit 65 Tracks pro Runde und 10 Runden pro Map
Der aktuelle Lido-Board hält ca. 2600 Runden, die von Nadeos NTT System getestet werden.
Das sind jetzt 6,5 Millionen Bitflips auf dem Lido-Board.
Aber das ist nur der Moment. Wie viele Replay haben sich in den letzten Jahren veröffentlicht?
Laut Big Bang hat sein Bot seit vier Jahren 7.740 Top 10 Veränderungen getrackt.
Das NTT System hat 10.340 Replays durchgeführt,
die 25,85 Millionen Bitflips betrachten.
Und das seit 2021.
Die letzte größte Update des Spiels war 2017.
Eine konservative 7.700 Replays zwischen 2017 und 2021
ist ein massiver Überblick.
Das bringt uns zu mindestens 45 Millionen Bitflips,
die das NTT System über die Jahre getestet hat.
Und es ist nichts passiert.
Okay, Chat, war doch ein interessantes Video.
Ich habe ja am Anfang gedacht, mal gucken, was da noch kommt.
Nicht schlecht.
Und was mich besonders freut ist...
Warte mal, ich warte mal, bis es fertig ist.
Ja.
Und was mich besonders freut ist,
dass ich mit meiner ersten Vermutung,
wo ich so voll ins Blaue geraten hab,
ähm,
doch ziemlich nah dran gelegen hab.
Ich mach mir das mal auf, guck ich vielleicht nachher.
Ich guck gerne Trackmania-Videos.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Wir haben
einen Computer aus den 60er Jahren
programmiert und Minecraft drauf gehostet.
I quit my job GitHub,
I quit my GitHub job
because I break software.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal. Wir gucken erstmal hier
Minecraft auf dem 60er Jahre. Wie sollen
das funktionieren? Im Leben nicht.
Das ist doch, das ist, chat, chat, chat, chat.
Das ist doch bestimmt G-Bait, oder?
Weil
die Computer auf dem 60er, das hat absolut
nichts mit
irgendwie einem modernen Computer
und Befehlssätzen noch zu tun. Also
da läuft Minecraft nicht drauf.
Wir skippen mal kurz durch.
Das ist ein UNIVAC 1219. Ein Computer aus 1965, der gerade ein Minecraft-Server gegründet hat.
Ups, ich muss gerade mal wieder, dass ich meine Lautstärke lauter machen kann.
Warte, warte, du bist auf der Kamera. Hat es funktioniert?
Es hat funktioniert. Ich kann es nicht glauben.
Aber wir werden zurückkommen, dass die Jungs es nicht glauben.
Ups, oh, oh, oh.
Minecraft-Server.
Warte, warte, du bist auf der Kamera. Hat es funktioniert?
Ich will mal ein bisschen vor.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Heller die Dinger.
Zu der damaligen Zeit
war der Schwanzvergleich
auch so ein bisschen, wer das größere
Gehäuse hatte. Damals hatten gefühlt
alle Big Tower,
wo halt kaum was drin war.
Wobei es mehr drin war, muss man auch mal sagen,
mehr drin ist als heute, weil
damals war so gut wie nichts on-board.
Die Netzwerkkarte war extra,
die Soundkarte war extra,
manchmal noch für irgendwelche Joystick-Geschichten,
extra serielle Parallelports oder so,
wobei die oftmals tatsächlich on-board waren.
Also da war mehr drin.
Grafikkarten,
später, später gab's dann
so 1997
gab's dann die Geschichte
mit
Voodoo, Voodoo 2
Karten, wo du dann bis zu drei
drinne hattest, eine normale Grafikkarte und
zwei Voodoo 2 Karten per SLI
und das wurde dann mit so einem komischen
Flachbandkabel durchgeschleift,
dann hat die Leute
noch Diskettenlaufwerke dran,
CD-Laufwerke, Festplatten, ja,
Also da war in so einem Gehäuse schon deutlich mehr los.
Aber so ein Big Tower war trotzdem zum größten Teil leer.
Modem.
Modem und ISDN-Karten gab es ja auch noch.
Ich hatte damals,
also bei 6 hat mein Vater,
hatte damals eine Fritz-Kart-ISDN.
So eine ganz, ganz alte,
die aber noch einen ISA-Slot hatte.
Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung.
setzen und sowas.
Capacitor macht mich immer fertig.
Ich kann mir immer nicht die Übersetzung...
Kondensator, ne?
Ich kann mir da immer nicht die Übersetzung merken.
Resistor und Capacitor.
Also Widerstand und Kondensator.
Ich bring's immer durcheinander.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Ein Computer aus den 60ern, ungefähr der Größe von 3-4 Kühlschranken, Seite für Seite.
Alles noch mit Tape!
Mann, ist das Ding cool!
Es hat das Frontenpanel, Blinkanlöcher, die großen Tape-Reels und
alle Ausgaben werden auf den weltweit lautesten Teletypen geprint.
Es war alles, was 60er-Sci-Fi-Movies mir versprochen haben, Computern zu sein.
UNIVAC heißt Universal Automatische Computer.
Und im Mitteilung des 20. Jahrhunderts war es die Nase...
Oder waren das schon Transistoren?
Sie wurde als der erste Computer bezeichnet.
Für eine sehr präzise Definition von Computer.
NEXs Aufgabe war es, Tafeln der Artillerie-Führungsprojekte für die US-Armee zu kompensieren.
Und um 20 Jahre später, war dieser Univac, Model 1219, die militärische Version der 418,
tatsächlich nicht so weit weg.
Von den 60ern bis in die 80er-Jahre konnten diese Maschinen auf den Kriegsflugschiffen gefunden werden,
die Radarhaut hörten und die geistige Missilien beobachten.
Heute scheint sich dieser Univec hier sehr glücklich an seinem zivilen Leben am Museum zu leben.
Er spielt das freie Spiel von Hunt the Wumpus und schreibt Ascii-Art-Porträte von George Washington und Spock.
Zumindest sah ich das, was er während der Live-Demo beim VCF gemacht hat.
Natürlich habe ich mich ein bisschen...
Ich will nicht wundern, wie oldschool wahrscheinlich heutzutage immer noch die Raketensteuerung und sowas auf einem Schiff ist.
Das ist bestimmt noch DOS oder so.
... eine Konversation mit den Leuten, die die Maschine funktionieren.
Und Wipp hat das Ketten ausgeliefert.
The answer I got was, not really, but there was a stack of about a dozen manuals and an emulator, if I was interested.
And, well, I was interested.
I got home, fired up the emulator, read the manuals, and got to work.
Being designed in the early 60s, the Univac here feels in some ways so close to a modern computer,
in other ways worlds apart.
Es hat Registrieren wie jede CPU, aber diese Registrieren sind 18-Bit-weit, anstatt 16, 32 oder 64.
Alles ist unter der Hütte, aber das bedeutet, dass jede Nummer, die man in der Dokumentation sieht, ein Oktal ist,
anstatt Hex, da 18-Bit-Werte gut in 6 Oktal-Digiten verbreiten.
Es hat alle Mathematik-Operationen, auch Hardware-Multiple und Verteilen.
Aber diese Mathematik wird in 1-Komplimenten gemacht, anstatt in 2-Komplimenten,
mit all den lustigen negativen Zers und seltenen Wrappern, die das enthält.
Selbst einige einfache Instruktionen sind ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen.
Hast du irgendwelche Werte für das, was Selektiv Set, Selektiv Clear und Selektiv Complement tun?
Wie es sich herausstellt, sind das vor Woodstock-Werte, die Bitwise OR und Annex OR sagen.
Eines meiner Lieblingsquirk ist, dass diese Maschine keinen Stack-Pointer hat.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht so genau angucken, oder?
Hier ist es fast gleich, außer ich benutze die Bayer Formulation statt BBP.
Es ist ein bisschen komplizierter, was ich nicht in der Relay Maschine gemacht habe,
aber im Software ist es fast kein extra Preis und es konvergiert ungefähr drei mal schneller.
Es dauerte ein Wochenende, aber ich hatte endlich den Emulator, der Stück für Stück Pi ausgespült hat.
Ich möchte mir klar machen, dass ich wirklich dankbar für das Werk von Dwayne, einer der Volumen,
ohne es auf Linux zu installieren, nicht ganz trivial.
Und das Assembler zu sein, ein QBasic Programm,
bedeutet, dass ich eine DOS-Box installieren musste, um es zu runtern.
QBasic, MonkaS, Alter.
Das bedeutet, dass mein typischer Test-Workflow war...
Okay, wie kommt das jetzt mit Minecraft?
Das kann ich mir nämlich immer noch nicht vorstellen.
...was Save the File, Typeback,
und dann live to run my computer.
Rust?
Und wahrscheinlich auch der Rust-Compiler.
Das Erwerben des Univacs war jetzt viel einfacher.
Aber eigentlich sitzen und schreiben,
als es sich an die heutigen Sprachmodelle handelt,
Äh, das ist mir zu langatmig.
Das ist absolut richtig, aber ich hoffe, dass Sie es verstanden haben, dass etwas so unakronistisch
wie ein 1960er-Computer im Größe einer Frisur mit einem Minecraft-Klienten zu sprechen,
bis der Klient sich dazu befindet, zu loggen, noch ein wenig cool ist.
Ein bisschen.
Naja.
So.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier?
I quit my GitHub job because I AI break software.
Haben wir bei GitHub gesehen in den letzten Tagen, ja.
Heute habe ich von GitHub ausgeschlossen, nachdem ich dort fast vier Jahre lang war und als Senior Engineer wachgegangen bin.
Ich bin weg, um die Sicherheit des AI zu verbessern, weil es einen gefährlichen Trend gibt, wie AI-Coding-Agenten gerade verwendet werden.
Und das wird dich persönlich beeinflussen.
Ich werde das, was ich beobachtet habe, warum es mich weggezogen hat und was ich damit mache, über dieses Problem sprechen.
Also, zuerst einmal, ich habe GitHub nicht verlassen, weil ich meinen Job verletzt habe.
Es war wirklich der beste Job, den ich jemals hatte.
Adam.
Ich habe es schneller.
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
couldn't ignore anymore.
Companies are not just using AI
for code generation, which I'm a huge
fan of, just like many of you.
They are now replacing entire parts
of the software development lifecycle
with AI agents.
Ja, das hat man
jetzt oft genug gesehen, dass das
keine allzu gute Idee ist.
Gerade bei GitHub, die Geschichte
mit den Merges und
diesem nicht sanitärsten Header-Input.
Testing, deployment decisions
and even architectural
und die aktuellen Entscheidungen an Agenten mit weniger und weniger menschlicher Aufmerksamkeit.
Und ich spreche hier nicht nur von kleinen Start-ups, die diesen Risiko beachten können.
Die Industrie-Bedrohung ist so hoch geworden, dass Unternehmen mit Millionen von Benutzern
ein Code verkaufen, das ein Mensch bis in die Produktion nicht mehr bemerkt.
Bevor Sie mich ververstärken, möchte ich nur sagen, dass ich bei GitHub
Ich habe es gefunden, dass es immer noch viel Respekt vor guter, hohen Qualität für Software gibt.
Jeden Tag.
Wie man gesehen hat.
Es ist nur so, dass die Industrietrend insgesamt die Qualität des Softwares schnell reduziert.
Es gibt bereits Projekte und Plattformen, die versuchen, die Grenzen zu testen,
wie weit wir die Kodingagenten bewegen können, um alles zu optimieren.
Und die Richtung hier ist klar.
Einige Organisationen belegen die Anforderungen als eine furchtbare Spitzkante,
das den Ausgang der AI-generierten Ausgaben schluckt.
Denke daran für einen Moment.
Der eine weitere Punkt,
wo ein Mensch das Code anschaut, bevor es seine Anwesenden erreicht,
und die Industrie das als ein Bottleneck nennt.
Der ultimative Schritt hier scheint es zu sein,
die Menschen zu überprüfen.
Das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll.
Dann hast du KI, die das Zeug erstellt,
und eine andere KI, die das von KI erstellt Zeug reviewt.
Was könnte dabei nur schief gehen?
Und es denkt sich halt manchmal auch Mist aus.
wie zum Beispiel
das da.
Das ist auch so ein dummes Wort, Alter.
10x Developer.
was produziert und ich bemerke das aber letztendlich so spannend ist es jetzt anders
die peinlich seien von der telekom moment das haben wir doch schon geguckt wir haben uns das
original telekom video angeguckt was geht hier was geht ja ich gerade in meinen shorts short
Vorschau ab.
Ja, das kennen wir schon.
Das haben wir uns ja vorhin sogar schon mal angeguckt.
Das wird uns das Video zu dem anschauen.
Hast du schon AirDev von JetBrains gesehen?
Was? Ne.
Air.Dev?
agent stellen natürlich natürlich da sind ja auch wieder am start
agentic development environment natürlich ist da jetbrains hat ja bisher auch ein
bisserl das nachsehen gehabt was die ganze ki geschichte angeht kein wunder kein wunder
dass die hier jetzt anfangen mit das ist doch flieht flieht gibt es nicht mehr vielleicht
haben wir die codebase genommen von fleet und haben dazu eine kurs alternative
oder irgendwie sowas gebaut keine ahnung was das gibt wenn es fertig ist
vielleicht ändert sich noch aber irgendwie ich bin immer noch nicht
komplett von reinem agentic coding kram überzeugt also als support und
unterstützung für wenn ich selbst was mache klar ja machen wir im stream oft
genug aber so dieses implementiere mir mal ein drop eine eine search drop
drop down geschichte in diesem projekt ich weiß nicht ganz ehrlich
Ja, das erstellt das höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich schneller, als wenn ich das erstelle.
Aber nach...
Wenn du das eine Woche benutzt hast, da passt doch nichts mehr richtig zusammen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Zur Unterstützung für mich immer, aber nicht komplett alleine im Baum immer was.
Wenn du das nämlich machst...
dann hast du dann so dinger wie header fields bei github die nicht richtig
sanitized werden und damit sachen ausführen kannst du dir nicht ausführen
können sollst ich meine das kann im menschlichen programmierer auch passieren
aber das hat zumindest die chance zu sehen und es fehlt der komplette
Durchblick im Projekt. Du kannst das quasi nur noch
über Prompts
weiterentwickeln.
Also, als
Unterstützung ja, als
komplett.
Ne.
Lea und Dankeschön für den Sub.
So.
Hol dir mal Cloud Code für 20 Euro.
Haben die nicht jetzt mittlerweile sogar
ihre Subscription übelst verteuert?
War da nicht irgendwas?
Ging doch letztens, letzten Monat
ging das doch so durch die
einschlägigen News-Seiten.
dass die Code Subscription
sau viel teurer geworden ist. Oder ne
ne, die Subscription ist nicht teurer geworden
du kannst es nicht mal benutzen
von anderer Software aus. Ist es nicht so
gewesen, dass wenn du es über die
Ach, das haben die rückgängig gemacht
war der Aufschrei zu groß
Da sieht man mal, was die Kacke ist, wenn man
sowas fabriziert. Leute wie ich
die das nicht täglich verfolgen
die kriegen das nur einmal mit
und dass es rückgängig gemacht wurde, kriegen sie dann gar nicht mal mit
Du meinst Kilo, nicht Kiro, oder?
Weil Kilo kenne ich, Kiro kenne ich nicht.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Ach genau, das hier.
Das BSI hat eine Schwachstelle auf meinem Server gefunden.
Hut-Informatik.
Hackermans mit Hoodie.
Kiro, Kiro kenne ich nicht.
Okay, gucken wir das mal.
Stellt euch vor, ihr hackt euch selbst.
Einfach mal schauen, was das Internet über euch weiß.
Ihr geht eure Domains durch, eure GitHub-Repositories,
checkt, ob eure Persona-Trennung hält.
Und dann, mitten in der Analyse, findet ihr heraus,
dass auf eurem eigenen Server Postgres offen ist.
Redis und Postgres seit fünf Wochen offen im Internet hängen.
Ohne Identifizierung, ohne Firewall und das BSI hat euch...
Wahrscheinlich wegen Docker-Firewall-Regeln.
...viermal geschrieben und ihr habt es ignoriert.
Das ist mir passiert.
Und ich zeige euch heute genau, was schiefgelaufen ist,
warum Docker eure Firewall komplett aushebelt und...
Ja.
Und ich zeige euch heute genau, was schief...
Also, ich bin nicht so pfeifert, dass ich das geahnt hätte, ne?
Das ist, weil vorher irgendjemand im Stream was geschrieben hat mit Docker und da wusste ich gleich, es ging um diese Docker-Firewall-Geschichte.
Weil dieses Problem hat jeder früher oder später, der Services hosten will, mit Docker schon mal gehabt.
Deswegen wäre ich da vorsichtig, auch wegen einem Public-Server einfach Docker zu installieren und dann sagen, oh ja, starten wir mal hier irgendwie was.
Ne, das kann man machen, da muss man mal gucken, dass der nur...
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz niesen.
Es darf nur auf Localhost binden
Und dann irgendeine Reverse-Proxy davor
Oder sowas
Oder diese Firewall-Geschichten
Gibt es ja
So ein paar Skripts, dass man das wieder rückgängig macht
Aber das macht Probleme
... mal geschrieben und ihr habt es ignoriert
Das ist mir passiert
Und ich zeige euch heute genau, was schiefgelaufen ist
Warum Docker eure Firewall komplett aushebelt
Und wie ihr euch selbst prüfen könnt
bevor es jemand anderes tut.
Willkommen zurück.
Du kannst natürlich auch eine Firewall-Kiste davor packen.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Es ist an sich eh nicht blöd,
wenn man das
ein bisschen größer aufbaut.
Sagen wir mal, dass du einen Server hast,
wo deine Application draufläuft,
davor dann auch irgendeine Kiste oder einen Loadbalancer.
Dann hast du das Problem nicht.
Aber
die meisten Leute wollen ja ein bisschen Geld sparen.
Aber da war nicht vergessen,
Also je mehr Kisten du hast, umso mehr Kisten musst du bezahlen, umso mehr Kisten musst du dich kümmern.
von dem ich nichts weiß.
Erster Schritt, meine GitHub-Repository scannen.
Ich habe mir ein Bash-Skript geschrieben,
das über die GitHub-API Commit-E-Mails extrahiert.
Das stimmt, bei Hetzner ist die Firewall mit dabei,
weil das halt über den in Switch geht
und die wahrscheinlich von ihren Switches
die Funktionalität dafür verwenden.
Ja, bei Hetzner kannst du die Sachen plocken.
Passt auch nix.
Nach sensitiven Dateien sucht
und Secret-Patterns wie API-Pi
Was benutzt er denn?
GitHub-Repository.
wie API-Keys oder Passwörter aufspürt. Zusätzlich habe ich GitLeaks laufen lassen. Das ist ein Tool,
das die gesamte Git-Historie nach Secrets durchsucht. Und hier wird es spannend.
GitLeaks hat vier Findings in meinem OpenThread-Repository gemeldet. Das ist erstmal
ein kurzer Schock, bis ich mir die Findings genauer angeschaut habe.
Secret your token. Da weißt du gleich schon Beispiel-Kram.
...Positives, also Platzhalterwerte in meiner Dokumentation. Zum Beispiel sowas wie das hier,
das hier oder das hier das sind keine echten secrets aber was geht liegt
zusätzlich verrät und das ist die eigentliche information ist die
e-mail-adresse und der autoren name in jedem kommit bei mir ist es gut
informatik gmail.com mit dem autor gut informatik in meinem fall ist das
konsistent mit meiner persona aber stellt euch vor da steht eure private
e-mail oder eurer klar name drin also unser zeitpunkt bei mir nicht
eure git commit meta ich bei mir steht wo bloß gmail.com oder irgendwie sowas drin was
wir extra nur hierfür registriert habe daten an und stellt sicher dass dort der richtige name
und die richtige e mail adresse drin stehen also machen wir weiter ich selbst betreibe zwei
öffentliche domains für beide habe ich gecheckt was sieht ein angreifer domain nummer eins keine
klarnahmen im netz punkt.de eine kampagnen seite gegen die klarnahmen pflicht die seite super
simpel aufgebaut und ist im grunde nur ein einziges html die seite verlinkt aber auf open petition
Und dort steht der Name des Erstellers der Petition.
In meinem Fall Hood-Informatik.
Also kein Klarname, also auch das in Ordnung.
Schauen wir auf meine zweite Domain, openthreads.com.
Hier habe ich den Whois gecheckt.
Ihr könnt quasi über einen Befehl gucken, wem gehört die Domain,
wessen Name steht da drin, welche Telefonnummer ist hinterlegt und so weiter.
Das Ergebnis für diese Domain?
Also erstens ist bei den meisten Sachen mittlerweile diese Domain-Privacy-Geschichte an.
Der D-Link gibt ja da auch nichts mehr raus.
Und selbst wenn da was drin steht, steht bei mir drin, dass ich Peter Wubblors oder irgendwie so heiße. Und ich kriege von meinen Domain-Registraren auch immer einen Hinweis drauf, bitte aktualisieren Sie Ihre persönlichen Daten, wenn sich was geändert hat. Und ich bestätige dann immer, ja, ja, ich bin immer noch Peter Wubblors, alles klar.
Genau.
Oder es steht Peter Wobblors drin.
Und da liegen vier E-Mails von Hetzner, weitergeleitet vom BSI Zertbund, der betrefft offene Redeserver und offen erreichbare Postgres-SQL-Server.
Kurz zur Einordnung, falls ihr das BSI nicht kennt.
Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik ist die oberste Cybersicherheitsbehörde in Deutschland.
Die machen unter anderem Sicherheitsstandard, IT-Grundschutz, Zertifizierung und beraten Regierung und kritische Infrastruktur.
Innerhalb des BSI gibt es das Zertbund, das Computer Emergency Response Team.
Das ist die Stelle, die rund um die Uhr das Deutsche...
Sind das nicht auch die, die letztens die Admins am Wochenende rausgeklingelt haben?
Ich habe schon vergessen, was das war.
Da war doch letztens sowas, wo sich ganz viele gewundert haben,
warum die Polizei nachts losfährt bei der Sicherheitslücke.
Erinnert sich noch einer dran, was das war?
Mitten in der Nacht, hier.
Bundespolizei-Einsätze wegen einer Softwarelücke
In der Nacht auf Sonntagwohnung in Deutschland-Zahnreiche
hat man jetzt von der Polizei geweckt
wegen einer Sicherheitslücke in zwei PLM-Softwarelösungen
Können wir das Ganze vielleicht mal abkürzen?
Product Lifecycle Management, alles klar
Hat's bei denen geklingelt daheim
Deutsche Internet im Blick hat
Die scannen systematisch nach offenen Diensten
verwundbaren Systemen und falsch konfigurierten Servern
die aus dem Internet erreichbar sind.
Und wenn sie was finden, schicken sie eine Benachrichtigung an den zuständigen Hosting-Provider.
In meinem Fall Hetzner.
Und der leitet das an den Kunden weiter.
Das heißt, wenn ihr so eine Mail bekommt, hat nicht irgendein Spammer euch angeschrieben.
Eine Bundesbehörde hat euren Server gefunden, gesehen, dass da was offen ist,
was nicht offen sein sollte und euch gewarnt.
Das ist kein Vorwurf und keine Strafe.
Das ist ein Dienst.
Aber es ist auch ein ziemlich deutliches Signal, dass ihr ein Problem habt.
Und genau das war bei mir der Fall.
Das BSI hat auf meiner Server-IP einen offenen Redis auf Port 6379 und einen offenen Postgres auf Port 2432 gefunden.
Ohne Authentifizierung seit über einem Monat.
Mein erster Gedanke, das ist mein OpenThread-Server.
Ich SSH rein, check die Ports und alles sieht gut aus.
Docker-Container laufen, aber die Ports sind nur intern exponiert und die Firewall steht.
Was? Wie kann das sein?
Dann fällt mir auf, die IP in der BSI-Mail ist diese hier.
Mein Open-Thread-Server hat aber diese hier. Das sind zwei verschiedene Server.
Die IP gehört zu einem zweiten Server, einem privaten Nebenprojekt von mir.
Ein Dev-Environment, das ich vor Wochen aufgesetzt und dann komplett vergessen habe.
Ich logge mich ein und sehe das hier. Beide Ports auf 0.0.0. Weltweit erreichbar.
Aber diese Docker-Firewall-Problematik, die ist eigentlich bekannt?
Also die hatte jeder früher oder später schon mal?
Und Redis kein Passwort.
Das heißt, jeder im Internet konnte sich verbinden, Daten lesen und Daten schreiben.
Bei Redis kann ein Angreifer über diesen Befehl und diesen Befehl
ein SSH-Key auf den Server schreiben und sich Root-Zugang verschaffen.
Das ist kein theoretischer Angriff.
Das ist ein Standard-Exploit.
Und was war mit Postgres?
Naja, ich habe mir das Passwort in der Docker Compose angeguckt und habe das hier gesehen.
Dieses Passwort im Internet seit 5 Wochen.
Ich finde, das sieht doch eigentlich relativ secure aus, oder?
Mein Dev-Passwort 1, 2, 3, wer kann sowas schon bruteforcen?
Wie lange ist denn das eigentlich?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
Okay, das Passwort ist auch noch relativ...
Also das geht gerade noch so, wenn es jetzt nicht so easy zu erraten wäre.
Ja, es sind im Prinzip nur Kleinbuchstaben und Zahlen, auch von den Wörtern her würde ich sagen,
Def, Passwort, 923 wird halt in allen Kombinationen mega schnell durchprobiert.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, da brauchst du wahrscheinlich 5 Sekunden, dann hast du das.
Gut oder so schlecht.
Jetzt kommt aber der Teil, den die meisten Admins nicht wissen.
Und der ist der eigentliche Grund, warum das passiert ist.
Auf dem Server lief UFW. Die Firewall war aktiv. Ich hatte Regeln definiert. Und trotzdem waren die Ports offen.
Ja, aber das sind die Docker-IP-Tables-Regeln. Also ordentliche Admins sollten das wissen.
Behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal. Also mir war es bewusst im Vorfeld. Dafür ist mir sicherlich viel andere Kram nicht bewusst.
Docker umgeht UFW komplett. Wenn ihr in eurer Docker-Compose so...
Wenn du mal IP-Tables listest, wirst du das sehen, dass das in den Chains viel weiter oben kommt.
etwas schreibt, dann passiert etwas, das viele völlig unterschätzen. Nicht Docker Compose selbst,
sondern Docker greift in die Netzwerkregeln ein. Sobald ein Port veröffentlicht wird,
schreibt Docker eigene IP-Tables-Regeln und die werden von den Regeln eurer Firewall ausgewertet.
Das führt zu einer ziemlich kontraintuitiven Situation, die ich auch nicht im Blick hatte.
Eure Firewall sagt alles dicht, aber Docker hat den Port längst freigegeben und weil seine Regeln
früher greifen, setzt es sich effektiv durch. Ich habe alles versucht, was man in solchen Fällen
versuch und am ende hat es zwei dinge gebraucht um die ports wirklich dicht zu machen erstens du
kannst genau du kannst einstellen dass es nur weil ich vor der auch sein lokalhaus listen
ports in der compose datei auf localhost binden zweitens und das ist der wichtige punkt jetzt
nach firewall einschalten die firewall einrichten eine netzwerk firewall die vor dem server sitzt
die interessiert sich nicht für docker und auch nicht für irgendwelche ip tables und so weiter
Sie blockiert auf Netzwerkebene. Nur Port 22, 80 und 443 erlaubt. Fertig. Erst danach war der Server dicht. Die Lektion hieraus, UFW ist nicht eure Firewall, wenn Docker läuft. Euer Cloud-Provider ist eure Firewall.
Ja, es ist aber, man muss aber ehrlich sagen, es ist auch Kacke.
Das passiert so Secret-mäßig.
Das steht, glaube ich, noch nicht mal irgendwo bei Docker,
Achtung, in der Installations-Getting-Started drin.
Also das Problem muss man schon mal gehabt haben, dass man es weiß.
Oder man hat es zufällig jetzt gesehen in einem Video.
Aber trotzdem denke ich, langjährige Linux-Admin, der sollte das schon mal gehört haben.
Nächste Frage, die dann durch meinen Kopf geht, ist,
Wurde mein Server kompromittiert?
Ich habe geprüft, ob es fremde Keys gibt, also irgendeine Art von SSH-Key-Injection.
Aber nein, gab es nicht.
Ich habe geguckt, ob es in den Redis-Konfigs irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten gibt.
Aber auch hier kein Hinweis auf Manipulation.
Und auch bei Postgres habe ich geguckt, ob es...
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte den Server trotzdem neu installiert.
...neue User oder neue Datenbanken gibt.
Aber auch hier nichts Unauffälliges.
Ich habe auch geguckt, welche SSH-Keys autorisiert sind.
Und hier war nur mein eigener Key drin.
Keine Cronjobs und keine Login-History, nur meine eigenen.
Fazit, kein Einbruch erkennbar.
Ich hatte also Glück.
Aber kein Beweis für Kompromittierung ist nicht dasselbe wie keine Kompromittierung.
Ein guter Angreifer räumt hinter sich auf.
Den Server habe ich nach der Analyse komplett gelöscht.
Genau, das hätte ich auch gemacht.
Es war eh nur ein Dev-Environment, das ich nicht mehr gebraucht habe.
Das heißt, selbst wenn jemand draufgekommen wäre, wären da keine sensiblen Informationen.
Und jetzt zur anderen Frage, beziehungsweise der ursprünglichen Frage.
Wie gut ist meine Personatrennung?
Das Ergebnis nach meinem Self-Assessment, meine Domains sind sauber.
Open Petition zeigt Hood-Informatik an und keinen Klarnamen.
Auf YouTube und TikTok ist kein Gesicht in den Videos, also ist auch kein Face-Match möglich.
Nee, du musst dir IP da vorschreiben.
So wie das eben im Video gezeigt hat.
Es gibt auch ein Skript, was diese Docker-Fireball-Dinger irgendwie wieder rückgängig macht.
Mein Gmail-Konto läuft auf Hood-Informatik und nicht auf meinen echten.
Man kann bestimmt, und da bin ich jetzt auch nicht mehr,
man kann bestimmt auch in irgendeine Docker-JSON-Datei was reinschreiben,
das da standardmäßig nur ein Local-Host bindet.
geht wahrscheinlich auch.
Meine Git-Commits sind konsistent mit der Persona,
also keine private E-Mails und keine echten
Secrets in den Repository. Okay, also nichts passiert.
... den Operatoren,
... für eine Masse an Menschen.
Haben wir
gelernt, man muss
aufpassen.
Hast du das schon gesehen? Kann ich mich trauen, das anzuklicken?
OPS
gehackt.
Ich musste mich selbst anzeigen.
DSGVO-Meldung.
Ja, übertreibt halt.
So, mal gucken, ob wir wieder neue Package-Updates kriegen.
Weil ich meine, wir haben immerhin schon einmal geupdatet vor zwei Stunden.
Das reicht nicht.
Jawoll!
So mag ich das.
bleeding edge installation hier vor zwei stunden geupdatet nächsten updates am start
mein chat rino haben wir doch ein chat rino gibt es noch ein update
Yes.
Wenn wir das kurz machen, ist funny.
Der Wahl-O-Mat. Hat das was mit dem Wahl in der...
Finde den besten Weg für Timmy.
Nee, der Wahl juckt mich nicht.
Ich will mit dem Wahl...
Ich will da nichts mit.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das machen wir nicht.
Kein Bock.
Das ging mir eh schon so auf den Sack,
dass überall jeder irgendwas zu diesem komischen Wal gesagt hat.
Und auf YouTube irgendwie bei jeder Mini-News-Meldung
irgendein neues News-Video aufgeploppt ist.
Timmy schwimmt in die falsche Richtung.
Timmy ist jetzt im Schiff.
Tierschützer machen sich Sorgen um Timmy.
Oh, Alter, Hammerswald geht mir nicht auf den Sack.
Das hat mich sowas von überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Du hast eine Frau auf der Straße getroffen, die meinte, der Wal spricht mit ihr im Traum.
Ernsthaft, wirklich?
Es gibt schon verrückte Leute.
Ja.
Nicht sicher,
ob wirklich, aber ich kann es mir durchaus vorstellen,
so Leute gibt es.
Hey, ich meine,
mein Nachbar ist auch der Meinung,
dass Corona eine Strafe Gottes war.
Besser gesagt,
eine strafe alas müsste man sagen das meinte ernst also gibt's leute die sind
da teilweise schon etwas kek alu unterwegs
chat ich krieg übelst hunger ich muss mal kurz auf meinem handy
checken,
ob es Essen gibt, bald.
Wisst ihr, wie ich das checken kann?
Chat, habt ihr eine Idee, wie kann ich
checken, ob es bald Essen gibt, von meinem Handy aus?
Der ist feifert
und weiß das.
Wer kann sich da was denken?
Strom, richtig.
Der Herd an ist
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. An dem Herd habe ich nichts dran.
Die Mikrowelle. Ich erkenne, ob die
Mikrowelle an ist.
Oder an war.
Und das spricht meistens dafür,
wenn irgendwie um 12 Uhr die Mikrowelle an ist,
weil heute gibt es nur Reste von den letzten Tagen,
spricht meistens dafür,
dass es jetzt Ballessen gibt.
Moment, mein Home Assistant geht gerade nicht auf.
Irgendwie backt das gerade rum.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Ich will den Valomat nicht machen.
Wir machen den echten Valomat dann wieder, wenn es soweit ist.
Aber nicht den Timmy-Valomat.
Okay, Mikrowelle ist nicht an.
Also gibt es noch nichts zu essen.
Sätge, ich habe Hunger.
Haben wir denn sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes, was wir gucken können?
Teamspeak Server selbst hosten?
Nee, wirklich nicht im Jahr
2026, Alter.
Ist das das neue Teamspeak?
Ach, das ist das
Discord Teamspeak
oder was? Nee, das ist Discord.
Das ist eindeutig Discord.
Sprach- und Textchatsoftware
ist einmal installieren die wenigstens das installieren die wenigstens das neuere
das neue ja okay das ist das ist team speak 6 die die mimen ja auf twitter
selbst schon rum dass sie keiner benutzt es keiner benutzt
TeamSpeak
People are using Password
Was das für ein geiles Aquarium war
Das da
ASCII-Aquarium
Kriegst du
hier natürlich Arch, by the way,
aus den Standard-Repos.
Guck mal, und ab und zu,
viel besser, ab und zu kommt ein Hai
vorbei und frisst Fische auf.
Der ist aber selten, der Hai.
Kein Hai.
Rare Spawn ist der Hai
Stimmt
Ascii Quarium Timmy Edition
Da gibt es noch eine Wahl
Aber der Hai lässt sich gerade echt ganz schön auf sich warten
Keine gibt kein Hai
Da ist er, guckt, der wird jetzt gefressen
Hier, zack
Stimmt, stimmt, es gibt, stimmt, manchmal
Stimmt, manchmal kommt da auch ein Wal, ne?
Naja
GitHub Copilot
Just died
Okay, dann gucken wir das
Ist das so?
Ich habe gerade ein Video über die Entschädigung von AI geliefert.
Es wird hier unten und in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
War die denn jetzt gerade wieder?
Das ist doch noch zu früh, oder?
Die ist doch...
Ach nee, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Die Abschlussprüfungen, die sind jetzt.
Die mündlichen Prüfungen sind dann irgendwann im Juni oder so.
29.04. war die.
Ah ja.
Und?
Gibt das die zufällige...
Warte mal, warte mal.
Von KS.
Suchfilter, beliebige Zeit, letzte Woche.
Ah ja gut, man findet da natürlich kein PDF oder so, das ist klar.
Wireshark und IPv6, eieiei.
Warum nicht gleich IPv8?
Ja, ich darf die doch eh nicht zeigen im Stream.
Was ein bisschen suckt.
Und lass mich raten.
Die Fragen waren wieder typisch dämlich IHK.
Sie sind Admin in der Alligator GmbH.
Ihr Chef möchte seine Tiefgarage mit dem Netzwerk verbinden.
Was schlagen sie ihm vor?
So in der Richtung.
Diesmal ging es um Kühe.
Was ist das denn?
Cleaner as a Service AI Washing Copyright
Earlier this month
Das heißt, das tauscht dann quasi die Formulierung und so ein bisschen aus
Beste war, sie sehen einen Auszug aus Wireshark. Bitte identifizieren, wo das Arbpoisoning stattgefunden hat. Und?
Die bringen Goldwood Railway und Grand Bazaar.
Na endlich bringen die mal alte Maps.
Die sollen einfach alles reinhauen.
Dass es ordentlich viel Content gibt.
Nicht erst
in einem Jahr nach Release so irgendwie.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal hier, was hier abgeht.
I just released a video on how AI
is going down the path of en-shitification.
It will be linked right up here.
Es wird alles entschädifiziert.
Warum sollte man das dann noch verwenden?
Haben die jetzt Copilot selbst gewipecoded oder was?
die sie gemacht haben.
Abriss Johnny, moin.
Ähm.
Was soll das werden, wenn es fertig ist?
Hat er sich einen eigenen DNS installiert, oder was?
Unser Internet hat einen Türsteher und wir haben ihn wahrscheinlich nie geändert.
Ein einziges System, das Vodafone und Telekom in Deutschland zum aktiven Blockieren von Websites einsetzen.
Achso, ja, der meint wirklich den DNS-Server.
Aber sicherlich habe ich meinen DNS-Server geändert. Ich benutze doch nicht meinen Provider-DNS-Server.
Alle unsere besuchten Websites nicht nur unserem Internetanbieter verrät, sondern gleichzeitig noch an die USA übermittelt.
Und dasselbe System habe ich für mich angepasst, nicht nur um die Sperren zu umgehen, sondern auch um Werbung und sogar...
Okay, das ist die übliche Geschichte mit eigenem DNS, aber mit irgendwelchen Werbeblock-Geschichten drin und sowas.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt wahnsinnig Neues ist, oder?
...Tracker nicht nur für mich auf dem PC...
Ich skippe mal ein bisschen vor.
...muss, fragt mein Gerät jemand anderen um...
...1.1.1.1...
Ja.
Mittlerweile regelt der DNS von Cloudflare 1,9...
Zeit kam dann immer mehr dazu, um durch Privatfirmen zu...
Als die Schutzmechanismen noch nicht so gegriffen haben, hat man damit massenhaft Accounts farmen können.
Aber auch bei mir zu Hause auf...
Ihr seht aber schon, Vertrauen braucht man trotzdem.
Domain steht.
Eigentlich gehen...
Das ist deutlich, deutlich...
Ja, das ist...
Besser als...
.de Domains ist das Danik.eg.
Danik wiederum hat das...
also ich glaube da ist jetzt nicht wirklich für uns nicht wirklich
großartig was neues dabei auch wenn ich mal fürs video sehr gerne guckt ich
glaube das ist nicht an uns gerichtet
vielleicht verpasse ich jetzt wasser war ich gehe davon aus dass es sich
installieren wir irgendwie einen edgard home oder sowas und den dns um so schau
mal kurz was empfiehlt mir der youtube in meinem browser hier der macht gute
videos da war wirklich gute videos also auch ohne tutorials und so also haben
schon einige geguckt wo ich mir wo ich echt gesagt aber er hat da hat er echt
ewig gesucht auch für die ganzen quellen und sowas
Oh, der Arme.
4K, äh, teuer.
Jaja, klar, ist teuer.
Aber ich würde es sofort für meine Katz bezahlen.
Ich hatte auch keine Katze mit Versicherung bisher.
Das liegt aber auch daran, ich hatte nur alte Katzen.
Und da ist es wahrscheinlich nahezu unmöglich.
was das denn in den zehn gegner zwerg ja der aua
Twitch Emotes
Long ago
Unterwegs mit Hackern
Das haben wir uns doch schon angeguckt
Da war erstaunlich wenig Gehacke dabei
Fireship
Fireship können wir gucken
Das ist wahrscheinlich die ganze Geschichte mit dem Gemerge und vielleicht auch mit den Headern.
in the void. GitHub is easily the most
important website in software engineering,
but more and more developers are yelling at it
and in some cases literally crying.
Ja gut, GitHub hat
ja auch Mühe gegeben, dass die Leute weinen.
...broken vending machine that ate their last dollar.
Well finally, yesterday, things
hit the point of no return. After legendary
developer Mitchell Hashimoto
did the unthinkable. He packed up his
open source project... Stimmt, der hat gesagt
ich verpiss mich
und hat einen riesenlangen Blogpost geschrieben,
dass er eigentlich der größte GitHub-Fan
ist und GitHub User Nummer 1299 oder so war und jetzt schweren Herzens GitHub verlässt.
Und ich glaube eines der wenigen Services, die tatsächlich
als Ruby on Rails App gestartet sind,
ist ein Großteil von GitHub
heute immer noch Ruby on Rails.
Also Twitter war beispielsweise
ursprünglich auch mal Ruby on Rails.
Das ist ja mittlerweile Java zum größten Teil.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch so für große Services?
Wir fragen mal Google KI.
Welche großen
Services
basieren heute noch
auf Ruby on Rails?
Na dann.
Shopify. Shopify ist immer noch
Ruby on Rails? Wirklich?
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Airbnb?
Ivor?
Twitch?
Das glaube ich
nicht, dass vieles bei Twitch noch
Ruby on Rails ist.
Twitter ist Java-based.
Also JVM-based.
Nicht Java-based, JVM-based.
Ist sie leise, auch?
Sogar ich als Linux-Typ habe in meiner Bewerbung mein GitHub-Profil reingeschrieben.
Und wir haben in dem Vorstellungsgespräch tatsächlich über den Fiat Champ geredet.
Hat der eigentlich neue Anwenderfehler?
Warum gibt es da...
Oh shit.
Will stop working in future releases.
Wirklich.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Ich hab das drei Jahre nicht mal geupdatet.
Die Entwickler nutzen es, um Storcode, Bugs durch Probleme zu tracken,
Veranstaltungen durch Pull-Requests zu veröffentlichen,
Tests und Anbieter durch GitHub-Aktionen zu runtern,
während sie auch als soziale Netzwerke und Resume für Entwickler funktionieren,
alle zu einem Git-Server zu ducktapen,
was genau das Problem ist, warum es so ein Problem ist.
Und der Hauptgrund, warum Entwickler gerade an GitHub-Aktionen sind, ist die Aufzeit, oder die Verlust.
Aber schauen wir uns die echten Rechner an.
Laut dritten-Party-Monitoring ist die Aufzeit an GitHub in 2025 unter 90% gestiegen,
and April 2026 is tracking around an abysmal 86%.
For context, AWS S3 promises 11 9s,
and GitHub is currently operating at just 1 9.
However, the official GitHub status page
Wollte ich gerade sagen, wir haben uns ja vorhin schon die unofficial GitHub status page angeguckt,
da sind es aber 88% Uptime.
... big to differ and reports Uptime well above 99% for all services.
Regardless, the previous week on GitHub was a disaster.
Am 23. April wurde die Merge-Queue im Jahr 2019 ungemergt.
In anderen Worten, die Plattform,
deren gesamte Arbeit es ist,
logr logr auch logr auch logr auch
Das haben wir uns heute schon angeguckt, ganz am Anfang vom Stream.
Aber das andere muss man sagen, also dieser Post, den da der GitHub CEO, oder nee, der GitHub CTO war das, glaube ich. GitHub hat ja kein CEO gerade. Gepostet hat war auch der komplette Witz, ne? Voll runtergespielt alles.
Ich finde es übrigens richtig scheiße, dass GitHub so kacke ist. Aus mehreren Kunden. Erstens, weil ich GitHub selbst gerne benutze und das zweite, weil Projekte davon weggehen und GitHub so eine schöne zentrale Stelle war, neue Projekte zu finden und auch zu sehen, wie viele Leute benutzen das, wie viele Sterne hat das. Das war richtig gut, einfach nur, so die letzten Jahre. Einfach top.
Also nicht GitHub immer, aber für neue Software zu finden.
Für mich war das super GitHub.
Und dadurch, dass hier so viele Projekte abhauen, hast du wieder total verstreut alles.
Du kannst nicht einfach mal gucken, ah, das Projekt ist wohl ziemlich verbreitet und well maintained und alles, hat 10.000 Sterne.
Kannst du nicht mal machen, das sackt halt.
Despite having enough money to own his own private jet, he still bangs out code daily, building a terminal emulator called Ghosty.
He joined GitHub in 2008 as user number 1299 and has logged in almost every single day for 18 years.
But on April 28th, he wrote a breakup letter while literally crying.
Speaking of GitHub, he said, quote, I want to ship software and it doesn't want me to ship software.
That line hits hard and he says he kept a journal for a month and put an X next to every day a GitHub outage blocked his work.
und hat fast jeden Tag einen Ex.
An diesem Punkt hat er genug, und sein 50.000-Star-GitHub-Projekt Ghosty
verhängt die Plattform für gut.
Das ist ein massiver Vibe-Schiff, aber wer kann sich dafür schulden?
Nun, es ist leicht, den Finger an Microsoft zu schicken,
weil es ihre einzige Verantwortung ist,
das Werk zu machen, aber ich kenne tatsächlich Leute,
die an GitHub arbeiten und glauben, dass sie es versuchen.
Die Schlüssel zum Erfolg ist
Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler.
When they acquired GitHub back in 2018, it actually got better in the years that followed,
with features like Actions, Codespaces, etc.
Das stimmt schon.
But now, in the AI-Coding-Ära, the enshitification is real.
Die Weib-Coden da halt zu viel.
GitHub's CTO admits, in writing, that since 2025,
agentic development workflows have accelerated sharply,
which translated into English means that AI-Agents are hammering GitHub like it's a free buffet.
GitHub isn't just a host for developers anymore, it's a host for their replacements.
In the same way Bill Gates saved the world from COVID-19, I have faith Microsoft will turn the GitHub ship around.
But if they don't, there are alternatives out there.
You've got the reliable but boring GitLab, you've got the German non-profit CodeBerg,
and you've got the minimal SourceHut, which has zero AI features whatsoever,
and many other viable platforms ready to reap the benefits of GitHub's downfall.
CodeBag ist Forgeo, oder?
Also was die benutzen.
Also ein Gittier-Fork.
Das ist jetzt ein Sellout, das ist jetzt ein Sellout, den er hinten dran gehängt hat.
Ich wusste es, ich wusste es, dass da hinten jetzt irgendein Sellout dran kommt wieder.
Der macht ja immer gute Überleitung, aber ich hab's erkannt.
Ecke.
Timmy ist frei.
Ich hoffe, ich muss nie wieder was von Timmy lesen, wenn das endlich...
Megazoff wegen Waltimi.
Brisant, Alter.
brisante Vorwürfe gegen Besatzung.
Wen juckt der Scheiß eigentlich?
Ja gut, genug.
Ist das
ein neuer
Grafikkarten-
Powerstecker oder was ist das?
Ja, noch nie in einer Wüste.
Oh.
Das ist der...
Der TempleOS-Dude.
Der Kerl ist so fertig gewesen.
Der Typ war so fertig.
Das ist der, das ist der, ähm, TempleOS-Entwickler.
Und da hat er auch gesagt, er hat TempleOS entwickelt, nachdem er quasi so eine Vision von Gott hatte.
Und Gott hat ihm auch beauftragt, äh, ein 16-Bit-System zu, äh, genau, 16-Bit-Farben.
Genau, hier, steht's doch.
Davis verkündete, dass die Eigenschaft des Systems wie die Auflösung 640x480, 16 Farben Display und der einstimmige Ton nach ausdrücklicher Anweisung von Gott entwickelt wurden.
Also Gott hat gesagt 640x480. Auflösung.
Will er haben.
Tja, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich habe Hunger.
Ich habe gesehen, die Mikrowelle ist an.
Jetzt Pippo Fat Time angesagt.
Es gibt heute kein Lachs mit Nudeln.
Es gibt auch keine Spaghetti Bolognese.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich, lass mal überlegen, restliche Nudeln mit Hähnchen, glaube ich, gibt es vermutlich.
Chatke
Mal gucken, jetzt wo mir es wieder ein bisschen besser geht
Ähm
Ob ich nicht mal wieder ein bisschen
Öfter streame, die letzten paar Wochen war ja nicht viel
Was wäre denn für ein eigenes
Hosting
Ohne Blick eine Alternative zu GitHub
Also ich benutze
Ich benutze tatsächlich Gitti, Gitti, Gittea, Gitti, wie auch immer man es ausspricht.
Und werde wahrscheinlich jetzt Forgeo benutzen, wenn ich das neu aufsetze.
Das da.
Das ist ein Gitti Fork.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich das hier verwenden dann.
Ist sehr ähnlich.
Aber du kannst
Du kannst
Auch Gitty verwenden
Das funktioniert wunderbar
Ehrlich gesagt
Keine Ahnung warum
Weil es mir danach ist
Ich weiß nicht
Soll ich das echt streamen?
Ich spiel
Ich spiel aktuell
wieder
Händeringe online.
Das ist super langweilig. Das werde ich aber auch garantiert
nicht streamen. Aber da bin ich ein bisschen
so versackt drin und grine da jetzt
einfach 5 Stunden am Tag
irgendwelche Mobs.
Ich mag so
Oldschool-MMOs.
Mit so diesem ganzen
neuen
Lootbox-basierten
Gacha-Kram,
mobile-orientierten Kram kann ich nichts anfangen.
Ich mag Oldschool-MMOs.
Deswegen spiele ich regelmäßig noch Dark Age of Camelot
oder so ollen Kram wie Herr der Ringe Online und so.
Battlefield-Stream.
Ja, wenn schon, dann Battlefield 6.
Wo habe ich zu dem Anniversary-Release
einen Priester gelevelt.
Bis max. Level und habe ein bisschen Gear gefarmt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, World of Warcraft
war nie richtig, das macht
Bock für 1-2 Monate.
Aber World of Warcraft war
ehrlich gesagt nie
so groß meins.
Ultima Online gibt es noch Server,
gibt es viele Private Server auch.
Aber Ultima Online ist auch nicht meins.
Mein Lieblings-MMO wird wahrscheinlich
für immer Dark Age of Camelot sein.
Es gibt kein besseres Group-based
PvP in einem MMO oder PvP darf man es ja gar nicht nennen, RVR.
Aber ich nenne es mal PvP, weil die meisten Leute eher damit was anfangen können.
Habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe ein Video von Theo geguckt, wo er erzählt hat, sie steigen jetzt darauf um, wo ich mir auch immer an den Kopf greife.
Der macht ja auch manchmal so Videos, wir haben schon wieder unsere Codebase rewritten.
So gefühlt machen die nichts anderes wie Versionsverwaltungssystem und Codebase rewriten.
Final Fantasy 14
hab ich auch gespielt mit dem Fabian
mit dem Frazier zusammen noch
haben wir sogar auch mal im Background
ein paar Videos gehabt
ich hatte das Problem mit Final Fantasy
XIV
hatte ich das Problem
dass es nach Max Level
außer Daily
Währungsfarmen
nichts zu machen gibt
du konntest
deine drei Daily Dungeons runnen
und sonst nix
es gab nix
und da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr
und es ist jetzt glaube ich immer noch so
nur, dass wohl
soweit ich das gelesen hab
die Main Story Quest
ist ja ein großes Ding bei Final Fantasy 14
dass wohl
seitdem die ihren Lead Writer gewechselt haben
wohl die Main Story Quest
auch mega sacken muss
Ich weiß nicht mal was.
Florp.
Was ist denn Florp?
Florp Browser.
Zeig mal.
Und was?
Ist es ein Firefox-Based Browser?
Okay.
Und warum sollte ich eher das verwenden
als Firefox?
Unlimited Customization
ist es denn Open Source und gibt es
den Source Code irgendwo?
GitHub, ok, Flop
Open Private Sustainable
Web based on Firefox
ok und was ist jetzt der große Vorteil
davon versus Firefox?
Das habe ich also nicht so genau verstanden.
Flexible UI Customization brauche ich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich customize gerne und ich bin jemand, der an seinen Linux...
Hier kann man nicht richtig tracken, markieren.
Das triggert mich schon mal richtig.
Ich bin jemand, der an seiner Linux-Config ewig lange rumschraubt,
aber an meinem Browser customize ich so gut wie nix.
Okay, das bringt mir nichts, dass ich das customizen kann.
Drops unique features.
Workspace features, okay.
Das war's, oder wie?
Boah, weißt du was, ganz ehrlich, ich sehe da jetzt nicht den großen Vorteil davon.
Ich meine, ja, kann man machen.
Ist das nicht die Nightwish-Sängerin?
Wird hier als erstes empfohlen, aber warum nicht?
Ja, aber dann hast du wieder irgendeinen Drittanbieter dabei,
der Supply Chain angriffen werden kann.
Und ich weiß nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich bleibe bei Firefox, Chrome und Chromium.
und gut ist.
Gut, ich geh jetzt runter, was essen, Leute.
Wir hören uns. Macht's gut. Bis dann.
See you.